all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibantis thai guy travis
full attendance mode on that thursday
last word edition but let's get with the
cheetah first nice vacation sir good to
have you back how you doing doing good
doing good um
vacation was a whole thing i've already
told some of the chat about it or some
of the hosts about it off stream had
some ups and downs just kind of taking a
vacation during the times that we're in
it was a whole thing but overall
definitely had some very good moments in
there as well so can't argue in the
grand scheme of things
um when i got back i just recently beat
grime and now i'm playing through
death's door as well so working through
a couple things before
the chaos of tuesday which you are all
looking forward to very much
what about you travis what have you been
up to sir
oh i've just been uh sitting outside
your door missing you while you were
going for two weeks i was kind of just
like
waiting for you to get back like where
is he
[Music]
hello please come home
no i've been i've been working on
reviews i finished a review for ign this
week i'm working on another one uh next
week and then uh yeah just catching up
on games like it's been kind of nice i
finished all of my destiny obligations
pretty early and i've been playing hades
and uh which i really shouldn't be
playing hades because i already beat it
on the switch and have other games i
should be playing but i'm playing that
uh playing a little bit of death's door
a little bit of uh
yeah my plate is just like i'm kind of
just relaxing and like enjoying some
games because like you said
uh tuesday it's gonna be uh it's gonna
i'm gonna be a slave once more
to the destiny sandbox and world
lord shacks he's gonna he's gonna beckon
me back to his loving arms what about
you dog what have you been up to sir man
so much man just been busy you know
trying to juggle the shows and
everything going on with that but
already shows you on these lord and a
dude or
a lord and a duke and a ninja in a ninja
you know many titles many titles but uh
yeah just been gaming man just uh ascent
i've been working on that i got a big
one think about a cent like
10 second review because i've definitely
heard some mixed thoughts on that thing
uneven uneven okay that sounds about
what i've heard yeah yeah it's it's it's
fun it's a romp with friends it's a
great twin stick shooter great cyber uh
cyber sounds about to say cybertron like
i'm gonna transform as well but
cyberpunk is a great
yeah that's what it was i'm in my
optimus bag but um yeah great cyberpunk
vibes the aesthetic is beautiful
some glitches some issues but a fun game
like put it this way for their first
attempt for a small studio of only like
10
amazing but they've they got the
foundation she's got to work on other
stuff but yeah i've been doing that uh
ps5 i've been doing final fantasy remake
getting ready for ghosts yeah get ready
for ghost tomorrow
so i'm all over the place i'm gaming
like crazy one thing being a dupe you
got a game because you got to be able to
talk about it
did you play this thing this week yes i
did did you play this thing this week i
was like
has got a gaming job now he's part of
the one he runs a tight ship maddie runs
a tight ship you got you got to play
these games fully so you had these
in-depth discussions but salute to hell
man
well
we've got yeah we got some amazing
person sitting here right yeah he's very
patiently waiting so as we do at the
campfire let's bring him in
let's let him pull up a chair welcome to
the last word number 163 it's safe to
say the hype train is running at full
speed as we await the showcase on
tuesday and yet we may have had even
bigger news today in the for than the
next year in destiny the crucible
landscape is about to change and the
campfire couldn't have planned a better
guess to discuss the topics of the day
this man came out of the womb seeing
targets on everyone's head and until his
first fps that he knew what to do with
all of that knowledge this man sees the
world of pvp differently than the rest
of us at least he has the kindness and
patience to present that knowledge in an
easy to digest manner with every video
he makes it's no surprise he has nearly
a hundred thousand subs on youtube and
will blow past that number in no time
whether it's some of the most thorough
ranking list in the business or some of
the best guides that can even change the
way you think about how you play this
game called destiny so let's welcome a
man who can
excuse me let's welcome a man who can
end a round of trials with just one
bullet who has more seventh columns than
all of rome a lover of the best input
method in gaming a proud member of
voltaic synergy and encore and a lover
of all things pancakes and wailing on
his guitar from his home in st louis
missouri the one the only patty cakes
how you doing sir hey what's up wow what
an intro
welcome welcome
how are you doing man i'm doing great
thanks for having me on i appreciate it
no doubt no this is a great show for you
to be on
oh yeah it's like perfect always perfect
for seriously you and sandbox and
ranking guides and was like oh what
happened sandbox exploded i'm like
perfect like the guy
yeah we got a lot of changes coming soon
oh yeah before we get into those changes
we got to talk a little history briefly
i know it's a big day but you know
you've got some interesting gaming
history sir so um one thing i noticed
like i said the fps focus which is cool
and you know a lot of destiny guys they
they had their start also in halo but
one thing particularly that resonated
was the lan party oh can you talk to me
about the people don't
know about that life talk to me
so i'm i'm on i probably qualifying the
boomer group of destiny players i think
and i uh yeah all of us
when i was in high school that was right
when uh
the first halo came out and at the time
there was no real i mean there was sort
of online play it was real janky but
there really wasn't online play for halo
so the way to get around it was to
do 16 person lane parties where you'd
get four xboxes connected with a router
and
order some pizzas soda or whatever
those are some of the most fun gaming
memories i've ever had i i still i miss
those dearly i mean they were just it's
so special having all your friends in
the same room so answer me this did you
ever do
a lan party situation like that so long
that you were still up the next morning
to go get donuts
oh yeah i mean okay pulled many
all-nighters there we go
now he qualifies there we go oh yeah oh
yeah yeah i mean if you're gonna even go
through all the work to set up a land
like you're going all night because that
is no easy task lugging those huge tvs
around back in the day
when we had crt tv
like dell crt 100 100 pound tvs lugging
up and down the stairs oh yeah shout out
to the big back tvs oh yeah good times
had the cat five cables and all that the
classic matches on what hang them high
and blood goats and all that good stuff
so absolutely i had to ask i was like i
saw a ladder i was like oh this man is
speaking to me
[Laughter]
trav you got anything for our esteemed
guest regarding his history
yeah i was looking um at your your
history obviously you mentioned you got
into um destiny like a lot of players
myself included through your love of
halo i'm wondering uh a lot of people
have different opinions about like what
or i guess different perspectives about
what really drew them into like the
bungee shooter because there's that
weird kind of inexplicable quality of a
bungee shooter that makes it feel not
like any other shooter you've played and
so i'm wondering what what was it that
connected with you and especially as a
pvp main i'm i'm a pvp man as well uh
what what what was it that kind of um
that you latched on to with the shooter
that kind of made you never want to stop
playing these sorts of games that's a
great question um so i think bungie
you know i don't agree with every
decision they make by any means but they
do a really good job with making guns
feel really good that's one thing that
they just i think that they're among the
top of any game developer in terms of
just making the guns feel really good to
shoot in the game and
they're just mechanics in that sense
have have been good ever since the first
halo and i think that destiny has even
improved on some of that stuff so it's
just um it's the type of thing that once
you get going with it it's it's hard to
stop because it's just even just running
around pve it's just fun to shoot things
like it's just you know the the way
they've designed the game is awesome so
yeah also the sound of the guns is
always something that sound design is
better there's like a certain like
chunkiness to like a bungee designed gun
where i'm just like oh man why does this
feel so good to shoot there's so much
variety too right you've got like the
amalan weapons for example like one kind
of feel and then you know text mechanic
is different it's like each different
like you know type of weapon it can be
you know one auto rifle can feel
completely different from another one
even though they're like you know
similar on paper so
it's just they do a really good job with
making them kind of unique and you kind
of find the ones that you end up liking
the best so
nice nice
yeah um before we just kind of cover
your like just idea behind content
creation which i do want to touch on a
bit i wanted to ask you to see obviously
shooters are like literally in your
blood like the way you talk about them
love of battlefield when you watch you
just hit snipes in battlefield in this
it's just like it's your skills are
crazy but outside of fps which is like
your wheelhouse do you have like dirty
secret games that you play off of stream
that nobody else knows about or anything
like what's happening it's a good
question what's your like secret loves
of other stuff
i've been a huge gamer my whole life i i
love playing anything um i'm not great
at shoot like the fighting games other
than like the smash bros i'm okay at but
like the traditional like mortal kombat
that's probably one of my weaker sides
those in the racing games i never got
other than mario kart as a decent mario
kart player but you know like the
traditional stuff i wasn't so good but
otherwise like i play pretty much
everything and uh i would say my
probably my favorite type of game if i
have the time is mmos i really love
playing them it's just
it's at odds with my job and content
creation here because yeah you know i
could ease like like the new um new
world coming out soon like i played you
know i was actually out of time for most
of the um the beta but i had so much fun
with it i could easily play that for
like 100 hours like it was so fun so
i can those are
dangerous territory for me i have to
kind of be careful with how much i play
well new world is terrifying because i
played days and days and weeks of world
warcraft same thing so it's like i
my my whole mmo and 40 person rating
started there so when you see something
like new world i'm like i don't know if
i've got time
because as you said it's like one of
those things especially if you want to
try and make it even partial coverage
for a channel or anything like that you
kind of have to live it
to be deep enough to be able to talk
about it with some intelligence which is
always the hard part
so no i get that but yeah it's yeah
the nice thing about nps games too is
that the skills are pretty transferable
so for example i've been playing split
gate a little bit recently i love apex
of battlefield call of duty uh warzone
like all the different you know popular
games and so
if you're decent at like destiny for
example it's not too hard to transfer
over and play something else whereas
like if you're you know if you're good
at world of warcraft doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to be good at like you
know elder scrolls online there's like i
think there's a there's more diversity
between those games that makes it harder
to transfer the same skills so that's
one nice thing about fps game if you can
aim pretty well with a mouse and
keyboard you can play a lot of different
games there we go bouncing keyboard for
sure about you look at him look at him
he loves that i threw that in the intro
at least hey the podcast is split for a
night for a change as opposed to me
being like odd man
that is true
and speaking of also split as far as um
sub class and and favorite class and
what get some hunter talk going man you
know okay so like um boy yeah we go no
this is good we need that we need the
first answer yeah
you know two titans here all guests have
to be hunters just to balance us out
exactly we need a hunter in here so i
need you to get you know your affinity
for the class and then your favorite you
know subclass within that that you like
to play so let's talk about it i mean i
always tend to gravitate towards like
the stealthy like rogue assassin type
players you know
what the game is like i love that like
kind of ninja type class and then also
hunters are sort of like the gunslinger
sniper thing too so it's like my two
favorite like archetypes of characters
in any game are merged into one being
the hunter so i i knew i was picking it
from when i first started playing
destiny one i had a brief stint with
titan when i got a fist of havoc for the
first time ever in vanilla destiny one
that i switched i made a titan for like
oh the hammers yeah um but then i
quickly uh was destroyed by a blink
shotgun um archer i guess uh
blade dancer at the time in destiny 1
and when i saw that super i was like
okay i'm going back to hunter and
that looks back
it makes sense makes sense no doubt that
so like i said like it was i got the
affinity because that was
kind of what might made me
get real close to pick it up i was like
damn cause i i like ninjas and the
stealth and the agility and you know
that kind of thing so i get it and um so
again would it be like arc strider like
what would the specific like subclass
like
really if you have if you can only pick
one yeah it's hard because i really do
like to play all of them and i try to
make builds around all of them and kind
of like stay diversified if i'm just
picking one probably spectral blades is
my favorite i just i really like i think
the super is really fun um i like the
you
i'm a sniper mostly and so you snipe and
get a wall you know get a head shot
while you're crouching at wall hacks
it's pretty strong uh but i mean i i
love playing orchestra i love uh you
know goldie spectral art the stasis
hunter 2 is very fun i'm glad that it's
been nerfed a lot because it was oh yeah
how many seven that was the only thing i
could justify
how many seventh columns do you have
with that damn gold
i've got a couple in the last week just
to mess around with golden gun
it's a lot easier in momentum control
though i have to admit
oh yeah
yeah
uh yeah so since we've gotten into
destiny stuff uh i guess we'll just
we'll dive straight in um
we do this pot we do this segment on
this podcast
it's a long running segment yeah long
running he created two weeks ago
and it's called let's help ebantus
and the way that it works is um
i ask our guests who are pvp minded to
tell us
uh one tip their top tip that sort of
uh that they have for people who are
looking to get good at pvp who are maybe
afraid of pvp or if you're like ibontis
um afraid of of uh everything in a pvp
arena because you know it's gonna kill
you uh uh so yeah
for yeah if there's like one tip that
while you were kind of climbing that
mountain top to becoming a a tryhard
that sort of helped you turn the corner
uh that that would be like a good tip
too so let me try to make it specific
are there any particular things you feel
like you struggle with pvp wise that
could be like you know because there's
some i could name a bunch of tips but
it's usually best if there's some
particular category you're having
trouble with come on he said i don't
know i don't think they let him into the
queue
anymore he's sitting the couch right my
man got you patty cake's got you man
break it down where the struggles at i
a couple times i've played with really
high skilled players and i know certain
things will come with time even if i
actually find myself spending a decent
amount of time in pvp
there's certain like situational
awareness i get a little bitter at but
it's
when you watch somebody who is at like a
different level on movement it's like
nothing else movement is one of those
things that it's not the only thing like
being aware of what's going on around
you kind of understanding lanes and
things
i kind of get a feel for those but
movement is something one of those
things can just elevate somebody to
another level to understand
each class's movement where to be how to
be how to get out of situations and as i
play a titan we don't have
well we don't have the warlock dash or
the hunter dodge so i feel like titan
sometimes like my feet are glued to a
ground so what do you have any big tips
for like either getting better at
movement besides changing classes or
or just like understanding it more
yes i mean titan is i would say a little
bit more restrictive in that compared to
the other two clusters especially if
you're
including top tree dawn in the warlock
category um
i would say that number one thing to get
really good at is just like the move the
the movement with the bursting and
skating so like um you can move a lot
faster than just running or just jumping
straight forward if you kind of like
time the burst if you watch um like my
friend serradius he's incredibly good
titan i would definitely study how he
moves oh there you go yeah he's like
watermelon
yeah he's a fantastic titan so i you
know i i would probably defer to him
more for the movement because i don't
play a whole lot of time myself but i
mean that's you know just
for no matter what kind of class you're
trying to improve on just watch what the
top players you know if you're trying to
get better hunter watch someone like
walla who's just you know has like the
movement down um so well or like my
friend glow for example on um on
warlock's amazing movement on a warlock
so there's just you know you find
players that you kind of like their play
style and try to like break down very
specific things and look for those
little patterns that they do like for
example you'll catch someone like walla
doing um a bunch of like you know jumps
where he'll bash his head into the
ceiling with stompies to get that little
speed boost but it's not just that it's
like he's timing that with the map
geometry to like perfectly hit those
angles to you know get a lot of speed or
for myself on hunter i like to do a
thing a lot where i'll like i'll slide
into a lane take a shot with like a
sniper and then dodge right out so that
you're only exposed to danger for like
you know a millisecond or something
that's right
it's a lot safer than you're just
staying out in a lane so i think you can
you can pay attention to like what the
some of the players that you respect are
doing and try to like steal those little
tactics that you catch in their gameplay
sorry if you guys hear the wolves in the
background by the way
no you're good you're good yeah
yeah well that one's definitely fitting
that's right yeah
the iron huskies in my house yeah they
are
[Laughter]
uh well yeah that happened but that's
fine
yeah so speaking of pvp though as we get
into all of this stuff something dropped
today that i don't think a lot of us
expected to see it was leaked a little
earlier
by one person another person we know
wrote an article and then they're like
well i guess we got to talk about it now
and that is the tweet and confirmation
of basically the soft launch of a new
anti-cheat
so
bungie is pairing up uh somebody
remember the company off the top of
their head battle battle battle line
that's it um
so yeah they're basically pairing up
they're gonna do a soft launch it sounds
like
for season 15. it seems like soft
launches see how it goes and then maybe
put it into full gear later on
but i mean i got three people who love
crucible in here and they talked about
anti-cheat which everybody's been
waiting on so i gotta get thoughts i
gotta go to our guest first sir patty
um thoughts what did what happened when
you saw this news super excited i was
actually kind of more excited about that
than even any of the other twap stuff
today i just i mean cheating is it's
such a problem especially and i it's
actually kind of reduced a lot of how
much i play trials because in fact i
used to be the type of guy who would um
i'd stream it you know multiple days
each week and try to like do
you know trials help and stuff like that
and it just like
it's to the point where you are almost
guaranteed to come across a cheater at
some point during a seven you know game
trials card and like last i think two
weekends ago
i played one card we faced i think four
cheating teams on the same card and we
lost our we we beat two of them and we
lost our game seven
back-to-back cheaters it's just like
come on like
that's just i that was the last chance i
played the whole weekend and i was with
really good players and that card is you
know the types of players who regularly
do beat cheaters so right just that's
just demoralizing to you know spend your
time especially if you have limited time
to play um so i'm really excited about
it i hope that
it you know is impactful and really
helps um i'm a little like skeptical
that this is like the
silver bullet that will fix cheating
like i feel like this is one step in the
right direction i think they're they're
smart to approach it with like the legal
side of
suing a bunch of these cheat
manufacturers having hopefully a better
anti-cheat built into the game i still
think that some sort of like a a paid
wall for like trials or like the more
high-end um things like that would help
like you know so you have to put some
money on the line to play those things i
feel like anytime it's just purely free
is you're still going to get a lot of
cheaters in there somehow or another um
that i don't know if any anti-cheat that
exists that's perfectly effective so are
you doing stuff like valerian
i was going to ask that question because
i heard to mention other places
battlefield being as that is going to be
full price i mean there's not a free to
play anything with regards to it do you
think that
are you excited for that at least i'm
very i'm actually it's so funny like
i've kind of changed my thinking on over
time like i i used to be so excited for
free to play games because i was like oh
man it's a lot more players and now i'm
like
i i personally would kind of prefer
something to be
if okay i'd prefer it to cost money if
that means that there's gonna be less
cheaters like it's you know that's a a
benefit enough that i'm willing to pay
for the game um so i don't know
battlefield's gonna be like either 60 or
70 depending on the platform i think for
the base version so
we'll see i mean that's a pretty big
deterrent if if you have to pop another
60 or 70 bucks out every time your
account gets banned so not a whole lot
of people can afford to keep doing that
over and over and over again so we'll
see um
but i i do think this is a good step in
the right direction for bungie and i
hope that uh you know it helps things a
lot
travis what about you man what what was
your initial reaction when you saw
sauron's eye on twitter i am stoked man
yeah i mean i i kind of had it linked to
me beforehand and and confirmed it with
somebody i know exclusively so
inside sources
yeah i'm kind of you know i'm like patty
cakes like i i uh i don't think this is
a silver bullet i don't think it's going
to fix everything but it will improve my
confidence a lot and as somebody who
intentionally does not play on pc
because i'm a pvp main who can't can't
deal with cheaters like it's kind of
scared me over to the console space uh
it'll be nice especially with cross
plate coming in season 15
um i my entire clan plays on pc so those
are like where my pvp
bros are at and it's gonna it's gonna be
great to uh
be able to play with them with a little
bit less risk because for me it really
is about the time man i don't care
losing to some cheaters whatever it
doesn't it doesn't bother my ego i don't
care about my kd my kd's awful because
i'm always just experimenting and don't
care about my kv at all
it's not about that it's really about
like if i invest 45 minutes on a trials
card and then i lose because of some
cheaters and it just washes away all
that time and it's just like i might as
well have just you know not done that
just conked myself on the head for the
past hour for 45 minutes that is a
really painful feeling uh and so
anytime i can i can avoid that i think
would be great i don't know if this is
going to solve a lot of it but it will
undoubtedly improve the situation
immediately and then i think it will get
better over time as
uh this service starts to kind of
understand the destiny landscape and and
really get in there and start to kind of
analyze um you know what needs fixing
and what safeguards they could put in
place but i'm pretty um i'm bullish
about it man i think this is gonna be uh
the beginning of something really really
great for destiny pvp and it could not
be coming at a better time with cross
play so
very excited
yeah yeah i mean i'm there i'm there
being
a pleasant surprise pleasant surprise
that this was something
i'd be honest you know with pvp i i was
losing faith
a little bit you know like travis said i
mean
he knows trials is my heart you know
obviously the trials of cyrus from d1
and you know that was a mode every
friday i look forward to fridays was a
special day for me
and then you know with d2 with the
fumbles with trials of the nine and then
they brought it back and you know we've
had our ups and downs with as far as the
loot and stuff but the main thing coming
from pc right which i was on after when
i left console for 60 frames per second
but you know when i went there it was
like yo fridays let's do it and it was
just so discouraging
just to see the wall hacks and just
things that you when you're getting
killed you're like there's no way
there's no way you know when you got
that look there's no way and it got to a
point where
i'm playing trials reporting people the
the meta was me reporting people after
the match
and i'm like yo we got to get them
sinister's in there now like yo make
sure yeah yeah that one right there
report cheating this did this behavior
and i'm just like and it just it zapped
my love it's zapped my love even on good
weeks
i became like the super casual which is
just go for the three card
get the weapon you know and then bounce
i
my desire to go flawless completely
eradicated and i went to console and it
was better you know doubt you know it
was a lot better it was less cheating
but this is what i want to see this i
want to see a an attempt to really do
that now i'm not completely familiar
with battle eye but i heard
good things i heard it's one of the
better ones you know i think fortnite
uses it uh rainbow six siege uses it i
believe so i did some research in that
regard and um you know it's it's it's
it's the right direction like like like
patty cake said is it going to stop
everything is it this silver bull like
no but
you want a police presence
you want
to know some patrols on the street right
yeah bro because it was they were so
rough shot disrespectful with how
rampant they were and just creating
another count it was bad e it was bad it
was the wild wild west out there man so
now it's like okay is it sheriff in town
granted it's free to play you know so
it's not you know i like paddy cane's
been a great point like with battlefield
it's more of a
cost when it's like you're gonna pay 70
to keep doing this you're gonna pay 70
right whereas it's free to play i get it
but yo this is finally the direction we
won and hopefully with the trials
changes that they hinted right
yo i i i might get i might be getting a
little excited again i might be getting
high but e i know you're not the biggest
pvp guy but like in general was was the
news pleasing to you yeah no i mean this
is something
if you're aware of what's going on in
the community at all it's like people
screaming from the rooftops every day
you gotta ask to cross being like
another week and another 12 without like
i mean
it's it's everywhere because of how
rampant it i mean when you see clips on
twitter of like an ac 130 dude coming
through with an infinite rocket launcher
just bombing the map i mean
the fact that that can exist and not
throw up a red flag in the game somehow
you're like how is he still that should
be like
like an instant switch be like you fired
700 rockets in four seconds
maybe there's a flag somewhere that
triggers and says that probably
shouldn't happen i actually saw a couple
other things
so it sounds like they filed three more
lawsuits against cheat companies
um and then also it looks like they were
looking for a data scientist as well to
help with i guess this type of thing if
you're looking at hey you have a 99
accuracy or something like that and be
like hey well let me go watch this guy's
play or something and see
is how this all works so a combination
of you know more litigation to hopefully
stop this you know it's like it's a
hydra you cut one off three more gonna
grow back type thing but
if they can get the anti-cheat in place
it's something that you have to choose
to install it sounds like as well so
you're gonna have to install this to
play it's gonna be a little harder to
get around i mean there's cheats where
you hear like it's running on another
machine with ai analyzing what's going i
mean there are crazy cheats out there
that these people come up with because
apparently nobody likes to play for real
anymore but yeah
they're doing as much as they can at
this point they finally actually like
hey this is a company multiple
litigations are out there
somebody leaked it early but hey dmg is
like well you know here it is and it's
it's as much as i think they can do at
this time we'll have to see where it
lands but i'm hoping this catches like
the glaringly obvious stuff the aimbots
the like you know ac 130s all that stuff
seems to be
hopefully stuff that this will catch
which is you know if somebody catches
you ever soft and you're like maybe
maybe not but if it's like the obvious
oh you shot me halfway across the map
through four buildings that probably
shouldn't happen
that's the stuff i'm hoping to see go
away because then at that point if you
play you're like if you question every
so often be sure like this is just trash
so
i'd like i'm glad to see that it is
getting to a point to where
they are actually owning up to hey we're
you know we're getting one you're gonna
install all this stuff so
be curious to see where it lands with
the soft launch and then
when they say like by the way if you do
it anymore you're like gone gone i don't
know how they're gonna work the soft
launch but still excited to see it come
trav what'd you guys say
i was gonna say you know what i don't
get about the whole cheating thing
especially cheating and trials
is like
if you're gonna get caught and banned
which a lot of these guys like you said
they get banned and then they start a
new account what's the point of cheating
and destiny if your account gets banned
and you have to create a new one and
then you're like earning rewards on this
new account that doesn't have any of
like your old stuff like doesn't that
it's money
it's for other people's accounts oh
you're brought in
other people's accounts carries trials
yeah buying trials that's exactly what
that's for so you're bringing other
people with you yep and you don't care
about your rewards for the people you're
getting that pay it is a business to
this
that's why people pay for the cheats
because they can earn it back you know
100 fold on a weekend or something i
mean that's that's the issue is the
money's involved so there's always going
to be money behind it hence why they
tend to continue to improve
mm-hmm it's actually kind of brilliant
you gotta hand it to him yeah oh yeah
they was hustling out here oh they was
there
they weren't working it was it was
working it was
this is like income for some people when
we all found out about the trials
trading like i i as soon as i heard
about that i was like that is brilliant
like whoever thought of that is like a
genius that's that's like i would never
have thought of that in a million years
it's real like i said i'm just so happy
that you know the the the the complaints
that everything that the community was
going through they had something
apparently this was supposed to be in
places like may or something like this
was in the works so yeah it's just gonna
be cool when we get the formal
announcement and like travis said we
know it's confirmed so you know it's
coming it's just good to see for the pvp
community man so once you get the
foundation clean
then you can really work then i say i'll
let off with the maps a little bit like
get the foundation right you know once
you do that
everything is good that i'll take my
loss like a man okay i got outplayed
that was that
that's funny you know it's funny i've
been playing a split gate like i said
earlier and one of the things that
struck me in that game is that they have
like a map voting system right so you're
about to get a map and you get to choose
like one of two ones that pop-up or like
a different one and people vote i was
just thinking about like in destiny how
much that would improve the map
situation because i think most players
it's not so much that there's a lack of
maps which there are but it's like
playing the maps you don't like over and
over again without any ability to
influence what except for leaving and
rejoining it often it puts you back in
the same one or it's like
or it puts you on another map and it's
just like there are a couple of really
good maps but you don't get to play them
that often and it's just like there's
not many other fps games that you have
no controller for which maps you want to
play yeah that's a good point i feel
like that'd be a good way to mitigate
the you know if it's going to take them
a long time to make new maps at least
let us have some autonomy on choosing
which we are going to play
i feel you brother or they could put
more in the game that they took out for
no reason really they could do that too
you can do that i mean
i still don't understand that not that a
lot of those were big losses but still
it's just good
laughing i feel like it's it's a good
day it was a good day waking up to that
great day yeah and then as the hype
broke twitter and apparently also the
destiny servers um at about seven or
nine a.m whenever uh dmg tweeted out
he's like hey everybody just tweet twab
anybody who follows destiny's stuff on
twitter it's like trending number two or
something right above only fans which if
you know the joke you'll get that one
but you can move on behind it
um
yeah
if anybody find no just kidding um
[Laughter]
but basically we knew from the previous
days uh dmg had said
like basically holy crap this is a giant
twab and then somebody showed a picture
of like page 11 of 17 and 6 000 words so
we're going okay we get a novel today
so we have a lot of stuff to cover i'm
not gonna touch everything in pure
detail but i'm gonna get obviously with
a lot of sandbox crucible people in here
this is the 12 for them so we are going
to hit on quite a bit of stuff uh there
are going to be time stamps on this one
so if you're watching on video watching
an audio you guys should be able to
click through see if there's anything
that interests you
first big thing about the twab they
actually go through and define a whole
bunch of terms what they want to say
them as kind of internal and external
and stuff like that
i don't want to go into too much detail
on these i know some people would like
love to like break it down people like
firing range our friend of the show
teddy
uh patty patty as well it's like all of
these people you might want to no it's
like so but there's certain ones that
you got fall off projectiles shotguns
are the big three
fall off they talk about the falloff
minimum to maximum basically like the
falloff start is when your maximum
damage starts to go away like the
maximum range that you can hit your full
damage and the falloff end is when your
damage of your gun is at the floor
whether it's a shotgun and it's zero
whether it's an auto rifle and it's two
that's the lowest it can do damage as
far away as possible
uh the second one's projectiles um they
had hit scan versus non-hit scan pretty
straightforward stuff if anybody doesn't
know hit scan weapon basically it
instantly hits as soon as you pull the
trigger on your controller or click the
mouse button wherever that cursor is
minus you know aim assist and
calculating everything else it
calculates right then hand cannons auto
rifles
bows when they're fully drawn things of
that nature on the other side you have
non-hit scan weapons picture yotan above
non-fully drawn grenade launchers things
that have travel time have physics
things of that nature
finally they go over shotguns they
actually cover the spread angle
and then also the way the cones are set
up i think this is something that you
know mercury's and the spreadsheet
masters are going to be finally getting
like okay this is kind of how this stuff
works because shotguns feel random i
mean fallout i'm sorry for all the
research he's done but he's like
shotguns are kind of random and then
they're like they're random but not
totally random because they actually
explain how a shotgun fires it has 12
pellets there's one at the dead center
then there's a inner ring
which has basically like a pie cut into
fourths and in those fourths somewhere
those four pellets can fall and then the
outer ring is seven
basically it's divided up into seven and
in those little seven chunks that's
where the other pellets can fall so you
got a single bullet four around and if
you've ever like gone up to a wall and
fired it you've seen this if you ever
have fired a shotgun pretty close but
that actually kind of explains how the
randomness kind of how it looks like it
rotates when you fire again there's some
change to it so it's not always going to
be the same but there's a general idea
to it
and you're you're doing this but based
on my experience with shotguns i think
the rings are like a lot bigger than you
you would think like just unless you're
right in front of the thing it's
probably smaller rings but they're like
they're more like cone rings right
because
they're yeah yeah
it is i get what they're saying why it
feels random because all of us have had
that shotgun shot where we're like what
you know a few of those just escaped the
cone and then kind of flew off into the
well you get like either side of it it's
like sometimes you'll map someone from
like way farther than you feel like you
should have and other times yeah
seemingly with but i thought this was so
cool i was actually one of the um things
that i would love them to do more of is
just give us this kind of detail because
i've always said i've suspected they had
some sort of a system like this but you
know there's no way to really know
unless you're you know buddy buddy with
the dev so um i thought it was really
cool that they shared this and i've
spent so many hours looking at shotgun
patterns on the wall trying to
understand how it works in destiny so it
was really cool for me to read this and
kind of you know get have some you know
mental model and i also think it's
really cool that they are starting to
share more of these definitions of
different things just because as a
community then we have like a common
terminology to describe things there's
so much confusion with like bullet
magnetism and reticle friction and all
these different things about you know
how the game actually works mechanically
and it's just it's really nice to have
some terms introduced by the developers
that we can all use you know to talk
about these things
yeah completely agree i just think that
um
all i think about uh trav and all i can
think about is teddy because these are
the discussions i would have with teddy
in a party chat and he would just he
would be so frustrated as to like why
isn't bungie transparent on how things
in their game works so we can understand
them better and we can utilize it better
and it it which is a hilarious complaint
in a game because no other video game is
held to that standard
nobody gets to know what call of duty's
cone angles are like or anything nobody
does anything else i want to know your
shotguns uh algorithm for how the
pellets are being distributed is an
insane request of a player like that's
like something you know maybe a
developer on the pvp team would ask on
like their first week of the job but
like not
something that you would expect a
community but that this is the the magic
and the curse of destiny is they have
that
they they are treated like other games
aren't because of their community and
their popularity and that sort of stuff
but yeah teddy always cracks me up with
his requests
i gotta defend him a little bit a little
bit because there there is a lot of
randomness with things that they
introduce and sometimes you don't
understand like at least with perks and
stuff like i could say i could
definitely say i'm like okay
i would like some more transparency on
again but like
what does a shotgun spread in any of
like what's the shotgun spread in
battlefield they're not going to tell
you ea is not going to be like well this
is exactly how the function of the
spread works and this is how the code is
crazy that it's like the the players are
so entitled to like i should get to know
what code is in your game like that's
why
i'm with you on the perks like we should
know
you should understand collisions with
that yeah but yeah yeah my thing is just
perks
flavor text when it comes to um
you know sometimes like when it's snap
bonuses like
what is that sometimes you're undefined
right sometimes you'll do something in
the game and then you'll see the flavor
text live in the lower right corner of
whatever that action you and sometimes
you like you want to know specifically
okay what does this really mean what is
what is because sometimes the exotic
itself or the perk itself doesn't
properly describe what's happening and
that that's all it is you know i
remember things like back in the day
with just like soros regime i would like
a pet peeve of mine was like the
intrinsic perk where it's supposed to
heal you
like why does it never come on screen to
say okay oh you know what i'm saying
that it it procked or initiated just
little things but to your point where
teddy teddy's a whole nother level of
ridiculousness
yeah i actually think you make a good
point because there was that thing with
armor stats for a while where we didn't
know what the thresholds were for like
the benefits and now that's all unveiled
i think they need that for weapons i
think they need it for
both perks and they need it for those
bars we have to know like they've got to
have some visual way of like showing us
what it means if i get a little bit more
range or whatever because yeah players
like pattycakes and i like we know
because we put a lot of time into like
testing it but but we don't it's not
scientific and it's definitely not user
friendly to people who are just like
trying to figure out like what their
preferences are you kind of have to try
every weapon and then figure out if it
feels the way you want it to feel like
that's not perfect a very it's not a
very good user experience i feel but in
terms of like knowing their algorithm
for like i want to know exactly how
fusion rifle was calculated
i'm like bro like just like you're ready
for a little bit of magic
you're in battlefield asking what is the
drop rate at this distance for this
sniper rifle no like that's not going to
happen but
i was going to say a high five
for you
uh a high mentality shot a perfect one
to chat zin moment that perk has bugged
the crap out of me forever because it is
ultra vague it's just like it kind of
helps stability but you're like when how
much to what extent it doesn't show the
little gauge move at all i think some
people may know but it's like generally
for an average person it's like i don't
it's some stability maybe kind of
sometimes like it's well yeah to their
credit they i think they have been
getting better about explaining that
stuff recently over the last like i
would say six to 12 months like
way more transparent but in fact i think
they described zen moments specifically
in like the dcp firing range podcast
which is so cool to have them explain
how that how all those mechanics work
but i would love to see it in the game i
think that would just be you know it
would be so much more helpful to
understand when it's you know worth
using versus you know not using in you
know without having to go all the way
externally to listen to some podcast
with the developer just to understand
how it works yeah thank you yeah
absolutely
yeah that's wild how into the weeds you
have to get just to understand something
that's in the game for every player and
it's like oh if you want to understand
that oh you got to go back to 2020 when
the devs were on uh you know some some
guys yeah
it's some guy's garage on their podcast
talking about you know it's just crazy
that that's the level you have to get
into just to get information that should
be in the game somewhere
but yeah that's that's sort of a
separate issue and i agree they have
been getting better at it but uh yeah
yeah the the i think they're going above
and beyond is my point with this 12
explaining stuff like shotgun spreads
like that's crazy and i'm sure people
like teddy are going to eat it up good
for them but uh yeah i think it's it's
maybe an over correction and they should
just focus on like putting stuff we need
to know like in the game but i i
understand why they explained it today
because you you kind of have to
understand how it works to understand
how they're changing it right what the
buffs mean yeah i mean that's kind of
the thing is like we get a lot of
information in this one but as you said
i just like to see some more of it in
the game pretty clearly explained
i don't need to know how the shotgun
cones work it's like yeah you can try
and figure it out but on the other side
if i don't know what a perk does that
i'm looking at in the game that's an
issue so
they're getting there it's it's getting
better
um but for the next piece we've got a
kind of interesting global one that i
think we've all been wondering about
season 15 introduces legendary stasis
weapons and we've seen some concern how
these are intended to work particularly
in pvp so here are some details i'm
going to read this one verbatim because
i don't want to mess it up yes
stasis power weapons are in the power
slot but all other stasis weapons are in
the kinetic slot this is to avoid
overcrowding the energy slot which is
fair
and so that it's reasonable to use one
in match game content the kinetic slot
won't be renamed at this time maybe
something they do later on stasis
weapons don't intrinsically do anything
different from weapons of other damage
types we've talked about that before so
sad face there
but they are the only weapons that can
roll with stasis perks which is cool we
generally intend stasis perks with
slowing or freezing effects to have a
kill trigger this being easy enough to
trigger in pve and fun to use but not
obnoxious to play against in pvp
so before i go anywhere else yeah um
cog you're just grinning like what's up
little nervous
what you're nervous of stasis no slight
slight concern
this is
yeah i was gonna say this is like
remember cog this was i think your
theory on the show about how they were
gonna add they're gonna add two other
elements and how are they gonna juggle
six and now now we have the answer
they're gonna put three in one slot and
three on the other yeah you know i mean
you know
again i need to see before i get crazy
but you know my only fear is the
you know freezing and slowing effect so
we just came out of the great stasis
purge of the subclasses we got things
finally to an acceptable level where
people in pvp don't feel oppressed
and i i'm a little concerned about
stasis perks running
in pvp i'm a little concerned yeah it
depends now if it's if it's what's the
exotic uh the the garbage one the
sidearm
no that's kind of the sustainable there
you go
the stasis right if it's to that effect
that ain't really hurting nobody right
you know the way the way it functions
it's not it is when i hold it well okay
you're a beast but okay outside of you
and the one percent but
my main thing is you know i just want to
see the functionality of said stasis
perks in pvp that's all in pve hey have
fun knock yourself out i don't care uh
my only concern is just the pvp porsche
i just want to see what that does i
don't you know running around with some
crazy
i'm worried about those but i mean
hopefully they'll be reasonable with it
i think they know that we don't want
another stasis meta yeah well we just
got out of it so hopefully they're
careful about what they add yeah yeah
i'm pretty confident about it and what i
hope this means
is i hope that i hope it means that
now weapon types on their element are
actually going to mean more than just
the match game because there will be
specific perks you can equip to each of
those weapons that have the element and
uh that that would be awesome because
then they could go back and do it for
solar arc and void and then those
weapons start to feel very different and
have their kind of own drawbacks and
perks and all that stuff i because we
were all focusing on the element we were
like oh what if solar had like burn
damage damage over time and stuff like
that since since uh and i think what
they want to do is they want to separate
the elemental damage that happens from
your subclass and your abilities you
know because those do have stuff like
stasis freezes and that sort of stuff
but they're separating that from
like weapon effects that are going on
through the mod the weapon effects just
normally they just take down shields but
then you can do mods that sort of
give them more kind of specific stuff to
that i think that's brilliant i actually
think that's like a great
my mind sort of was racing when i read
this because i was thinking about like
if i was designing this game like why
would i set it up this way right i was
just thinking like oh my god they're
going to have three elements at the top
you know the top kinetic slot which
they're going to rename and they're not
going to call it kinetic plus stasis so
that means there's gonna be other stuff
like they sort of have showed their hand
right yeah yeah yeah we're gonna have
light and dark weapons
yes yeah like they're they're that's
sort of just like i if that doesn't
happen like we're all gonna be shocked
because it's like so obvious uh and then
and then the fact that there's going to
be stasis perks means of course there'll
be perks for the other ones because then
you know it's it's sort of like their
plans to change the old uh so like
subclasses and supers and stuff like
they have to do that because right that
consolidation some sort of parody yeah
and so i i think like looking ahead i'm
just imagining what the sandbox is gonna
be like and it makes me really excited
it's like this sandbox where we've got
six different weapon types and all the
weapons have different kind of mods and
then on the armor side there's the
energy types also have their own mods
and we don't even know if there's going
to be stasis armor or whatever the other
ones are don't get excited
they gotta do something
yeah i know he talks about it every
single episode patriots video watch the
show um
every episode he complains about the
armor
you don't blame him we're like
you just don't want to hear it again
there's something i don't want to hear
but that segment already happened so
that's fine
don't worry i like when you complain
i love it i would just say for me
part of it as you guys see it's like if
they don't intrinsically do anything
different so when we joked about like
match game is just being like play the
color game that is still what we're
gonna do and i just kind of wonder as
you guys are saying it's like i do
they
it was gonna be too much of a band in
the butt if stasis weapons started
slowing you down if solar weapons caused
a burn if art caused like a shock or
some weird like the game is not built to
do that unless they like
probably went so far down the code
they'd never get back out
so this is actually a way as you said
travis to have different perk pools on
different weapons in the long run solar
weapons get their own things art gets
their own thing stasis gets its own
weapon
perks that do certain things and that's
a way for them to differentiate give you
more reason to grind different weapons
and that type of thing so of all
i'm it's not like you know the true like
rpg was kind of hoping because it's
still the whole thing of like
you know if i fire a solar weapon or if
i'm like on fire and i get frozen it
seems kind of backwards but i think with
the system they built seven years into
the game this is the best thing i think
they could have done to differentiate
the weapons i will give them that for
sure so
just imagine the possibilities because
like that's the reason i'm not super
worried about stasis because my first
thought isn't like oh yeah every gun is
going to have a mod where you can freeze
a person like there's just no chance of
that happening because
this the subclass subclasses barely even
freeze you anymore right so it just
wouldn't make sense to put in a weapon
and if they do it'll be an exotic or
something you know like the the sidearm
or whatever but i'm thinking like there
there's a now a potential for the
weapons to have like an interplay with
each other like maybe there's a mod
where if somebody's affected by stasis
damage using solar damage like melts
them and does extra damage or stuff like
there's there's so many like
possibilities of how the elements could
interplay with each other and i'm just
like sitting here like if i'm a
developer i'm super stoked about the
possibilities of you know what what lies
ahead
shout out interesting i was going to say
shout out real quick to minnie swift to
the last word the campfire is lit thank
you for the super chat
appreciate the love of course what were
you going to say patty sorry i'm just
going to say i like i'm i'm so torn on
this whole thing because on one hand i
love the pve side of like what could be
possible i want i want to see the game
turn more into like a diablo like crazy
system with all these interactions and
like deep builds and reasons to like
really master it
but then on like i get so worried about
pvp because
the community is amazing at finding the
most busted things and experts
and then just like man like
what are we getting ourselves into uh
because like part of me always wants to
like have the more pure like halo
feeling gunplay where it's just
predictable and like yeah you know what
to expect so but i don't know it's it's
it's also not we're never gonna get that
in destination
we're never gonna get that exactly so
i'm trying to you know i'm always trying
to be open-minded about that new stuff
but it does concern me just because
we've had so many cycles of this where
you know like
this is the perfect example of something
that comes in a little too hot and and
i'm actually okay with that as long as
it gets tuned quickly i think the
problem with stasis was
it was months and months and months
before it got adjusted like if if all
the changes that happened now happened
like two months in it wouldn't have been
such a big deal yeah but you know yes it
kind of ruined like a year of pvp yeah
when you listen
well that's the sad thing too is you
said even when they released it if you
listen to fire range they're like oh
this is gonna have to get taken down
four times they knew that and it still
took them this long so that always again
asks like
i know you want to release strong so
people buy the beyond light expansion
but maybe not four times the corrections
so long yeah
and then there's always the business
debate that we have too so it's always
very interesting but also from a
development standpoint i believe when
they were on shout out to again firing
range it was pretty amazing uh the devs
they had on and the vibe i got it's that
it's that it's that what is it that two
season ahead cadence yeah it's about six
yeah so once they put it in it's more of
a development thing where it's like okay
yeah we are realizing it's hot but we
really have the development cycle time
to be able to tune so it's like okay
we're gonna have to get to that later
and they're gonna have to deal with this
coming out for a while and i i think
that they get caught up in that cadence
and that that was the way i i felt it
was described in that interview and
stuff like that but yeah i think like
you said e they know as a dev you know
going in like internally like yeah this
might be a bit much but we just ain't
got time right now because we're working
on the next two things or whatever and
we'll get to it got to do
yep come over to my side pattycakes let
yourself be hyped because like honestly
the destiny's never going to be balanced
we know that halo infinite is there if
you want the pure arena multiplayer you
know it'll be out this fall for you if
you if you need that but let's just no
i'm usually the pessimist on this page
right now yeah we switch roles
i actually i i tend to try to be more
optimistic and then get proven wrong in
destiny i feel like it makes me happier
if i if i
as opposed to just like assuming that
everything's gonna break everything uh
because
you can either you know obviously go
either way on most big patches like for
example the slide thing that happened
like i yeah
maybe it'll break the game i don't know
i my
conscience that it probably won't be
that noticeable kind of like the recoil
changes that happened yeah a few months
ago so like i i try to generally
speaking
think optimistically it's just that i
also feel like this system has it's like
with great power comes great
responsibility
they have to be careful of how they
implement
well
more changes coming uh this one i don't
need to spend a ton of time on but they
are fixing the quick swap
situation which yep they mentioned we
all know about that yeah they knew it
was coming it's finally gonna happen so
the slug shotgun quick swap glitch it's
you know gonna have to kill the bosses
in a different way and we'll get to
another reason why you're gonna have to
kill the bosses in even different way
but that's an exotic we'll touch on
later but this one is kind of big this i
did not expect at all yeah running out
of this this was when my jaw hit the
floor yeah i'll show you i was i was
reading through sandbox i'm like oh we
got crazy definitions okay we got this
i'm like oh this i did not expect
because
primary ammo is now infinite that's like
the
that's one of the biggest changes
they've made just at a fundamental level
in quite a long time
so a couple other things right now is
actually kind of gone because you're not
gonna see it drop anymore it's it's not
something you ever have to worry about
no mods for it's just kind of gone yeah
so speaking of how that changes things
up they said inertia override by the way
can somebody tell me what that does off
top my head i forget
[Music]
has been adjusted to account for there
being no primary bricks
uh a couple other while you guys looked
that up drop mag
downside of reducing reserve ammo is now
almost meaningless so now it has
increased reload speed but does increase
magazine size which that kind of sucks
personally but oh well
uh compact aeroshaft upside of
increasing reserve ml now it's up reload
and handling
they updated some other perks that refer
to reserves because there's no longer
primary reserves uh reloads on a slide
and boosts weapon damage okay gotcha so
it has been accounted for that type of
thing and then they see notes on
fighting line sweep business there's
exotics down below we'll talk about but
i mean
you'll literally never run out of
primary ammo in anything pvp pv gambit
doesn't matter it's always what do you
guys like what did this do
so the first thing that i thought of
actually it's kind of funny but
obviously the worried about fighting
lines stuff like that which they said
they would address so i was like they
probably have a plan for that what what
actually came to me first though was
actually in pve thinking about um when
you're doing difficult like activities a
lot of times you'll rely on pity ammo
right you'll yes your primary and wait
until you get some like green and purple
back
on now yeah like what's gonna happen are
you gonna just have to use your uh yeah
even like i was doing um
i don't know like i think uh gm or
something recently i had no ammo and
it's like also neo it gives you back so
yes i'm really curious to see what
happens with that
inertia override is a titan ability that
allows uh picking up ammo during a slide
reload your equipped weapon increases
damage for a short time okay so
there's some stuff like that where like
there's a lot of abilities that rely on
you picking up ammo and picking up ammo
is going to happen way less now because
it's just special and power so it's it's
going to change a ton of
question stuff like they yeah like the
auto rifle that shoots forever and oh
that's going to be business with action
just like
you know somebody mentioned one in chat
huckleberry
huckleberry if you could actually have
enough enemies coming at you you would
literally never stop firing yeah that
would actually be really good for add
clear just on like a
like managing level just to always be
firing when that works for me man i mean
it's only gonna affect pve right you're
not gonna get an infinite huckleberry
kills and yeah unless
you're really something changes yeah but
it's like that it gives us oh i was just
going to say just give some of the
primary weapons
because there are times you're like i'm
out of scout right it feels bad they
kind of said that and it's like i'm
plinking away from long range and as you
said you may not get the influx now of
like special and heavy if you're going
for the other stuff if you empty
everything but you're always gonna have
something to fire which
probably in the grand scheme is good
because you know the waiting for the
other be like oh no i found a brick or i
got this other thing i got to fire the
stupid weapon for a while you'll always
be able to at least fire something which
that generally is a good feeling
yeah i was just thinking about uh what
battery case uh the main thing where it
comes into it's always that in-game
content when you you know obviously i
just started doing gms and recently and
yeah it's it's a deal when you're trying
to stay from distance to not get hurt a
lot of times you know i've got like a a
really good vision well even though
that's energy but you know scouts if
you're using a night watch or whatever
it is you're using and um
yeah you will run out you'll run out and
you wait for that pity drop that you did
yeah you scurry you see it and then you
run back to your corner you know kind of
thing
vision is a is an energy but it still
uses primary ammo right yeah so that
would be that would fall under the
infinite ammo now yeah it's just are
there any are there any exotics or
specials that like use primary ammo
besides
the only
that's literally the only one that
mentioned it down below okay yeah i'm
wondering if there's like some outlier
we're forgetting about that's totally
going to mess up yeah
or something yeah no you're right i mean
it's going to be interesting
i'm just thinking about my good old
outbreak perfected
right now with the catalyst
it's looking really good baby outbreak
perfect breakfast dps yeah like that's
it's always been a good deep you gotta
change a lot it really is
there's gonna be some shifts
going on and that excites me that risk
runner somebody else mentioned
yeah yeah they're just
exact exotic primaries needed some love
and this isn't going to make them like
game changers because you know
sorry could tell you somebody's going to
say but i was like there are certain
ones that this will help a little bit if
they can get like the buff that they
need this will give them that extra life
you're like i've always got exotic i've
always got an exotic weapon on you know
ready to draw out that has some benefit
to it like that's going to give the
primaries the ones that are weaker
because a lot of people run heavies or
specials it's going to give them a
little more chance
i was thinking that the ball was going
off exotic primaries is heating up right
now would you what you thinking i was
thinking
what about the rally barricade that they
just buffed but they just that whole
thing that it that it puts ammo in your
gun
because it used to be that it would like
give you ammo but they changed it so
like if you have infinite ammo now
bro exotic and that might actually be
good right and they've made a point to
say as we go on with the dwarf that they
are looking at making exotic primaries
more viable because let's be real we
doing end game content it's like yo what
heavy exotic are you using for you know
said activity to make it easier but
this is a this is a subtle yet
fundamental change that has epic
proportions and i'm excited i'm excited
there's a lot to look at with this one
yeah dude cog because like
why would you if you're in an encounter
where where ammo is at all a concern and
you're you have to make your entire
build about like juggling heavy ammo or
special ammo why wouldn't you just
choose an exotic primary that you never
is is never going to run out and then
all of you guys just jump on that like
like yeah like
and mind you remember they just killed
they killed scavenger perks didn't they
they did double scavenger they killed
yeah double scavengers not gonna do
anything
yeah yeah they're making it a point that
like
primaries gonna have more value they're
they're definitely increasing the value
and minimizing the reliance on the
others which i don't have a problem with
i'm actually
i'm okay with so far i want to see it in
implementation but so far this is a big
meta shift i like what i mean it'll be
wild yeah i'll break perfect boys
[Laughter]
pattycakes what's your take on this what
are we what are you going to break so i
mean i i first of all i agree with you
that i i think that the
it seems like they're shifting
weapons closer to what it was maybe in
like vanilla d2 like the double primary
thing of course but like without
actually double priming but it's kind of
shifting back towards that like special
weapons across the board have gotten
nerfed like quite a bit recently and
which i'm i'm personally fine with i
think that i i
i'll take a primary duel any day over a
special weapon duel
especially in pvp yeah yeah we haven't
talked about it yet but they they've
finally talked a little bit about um
grenade launchers which i'm so happy
they're doing something about because
those are i think so strong right now
it's nasty yeah yeah yo
it's gonna be crazy withering horde
though is still gonna be still gonna be
nasty they're not gonna change that one
yeah
well here's like one bullet but i know i
gotta ask this crew
target farming trials weapons is much
more efficient in season 15. we don't
know why yet but we're gonna figure that
on on tuesday and we have some cool new
perks for players to play with that we
want to put on trials weapons all trials
weapons available in season 15 now have
seven perks in each column was five
uh for my crucible crew thoughts whoever
wants to jump in just go i'm just hoping
that they implement something similar to
their raid
loot system like the what you get the
end of any of the modern raids like i
think that's such a good system where
you can play the thing until you get the
drop and then you can force
you know focus and farm whatever you
actually want from it nice you know it's
like for example it took me a long time
to get vape bringer but once i finally
got one that i could put tokens into
that until i got like the one that i
want and that's all i want from trials i
i've played so much trials and never
gotten the the role that i wanted like
and then the other thing about the the
perks is great too because there's for
example on the eye of soul there was
opening shot and snapshot together i
played so much trials i went flawless so
many times and i never got that role
and then they took it away so it's
impossible to get that right now it's
about the closest you can get is like
moving target snapshots so i'm hoping
that maybe some of those things will
come back where you have you know some
of the old roles that you couldn't get
anymore like maybe that'll be a
possibility again all i want is one yeah
all i want is one yeah they should put
one of those chests in the lighthouse
you know yeah one of those chests just
like at the end of a raid where you can
just buy any weapon you've already
unlocked i agree i think that's a great
idea what uh
patty kick said all i want is one extra
can we get celerity as this intrinsic
part of this uh package here
i mention it later on and the issue with
that is the idea of too many perks
working on one gun at the same time
we've talked about the technical
limitations
and they mentioned it again
running around
messing people's perks up in pvp
but you know it is what it is but let's
get let's get to it but now this is good
this is good i mean overall
they they they trials is getting
exciting with this and if they put some
type of farm thing where you can target
specifically i like that and yeah what
about spoils what about you know let's
let's go all out with it let's get that
same level of raid love why travis is in
deep though what is travis think he is
like plotting right now he's got the
diabolical evil genius what is going on
travis what is your doctor evil cat come
on yes
i'm actually so i was thinking yeah i
was thinking about perks on trials
weapons is like that's where my brain
goes apparently most of the time i'm
thinking about destiny but no what i'm
working what i'm more interested in is
actually the first clause in that
sentence right before the comma which is
like
you know uh tr trials farming or target
farming trials weapons is much more
efficient in season 15 like
we don't that's the part we don't know
like two new perks on each each column
whatever like i'm sure i'm sure it'll be
okay but like two new perks i don't get
out of bed for that
uh but making it easy for target farming
yes that's the one yeah i'm interested
i'm interested now reduce the cheaters
and we'll talk like that's i'm so yeah
we'll see where it goes but yeah i was
literally just thinking about perk
combinations and the the thought of
having infinite primary it's it's kind
of blowing my mind somebody said it's
like a very small thing because they put
it in the middle of 12 but i don't i
think that's the biggest news by far
that we got today and it's going to
change the sandbox in a hundred ways we
haven't even thought of yet that's huge
it's definitely huge for sure
yeah um so the next piece we've got is
they said when it comes to some of the
weapons that they've reissued
very specific examples being the ones
that came with the recent patch that
came back from both dreaming city and
the moon
a lot of those weapons to put it nicely
are not the best
uh the perk pools are not great and
basically they said
they wanted to if they reissued weapons
they wanted to make sure they had new
perks on them
but they also said that was a bit of an
over-correction because it got rid of
the perks that a lot of people still
wanted or had an identity with a weapon
so what they've stated is going forward
they're going to be adjusting some of
those other weapons as well
um any reissues that do happen they're
gonna remove the least useful about two
to three perks on any weapon and add two
to three newer perks to kind of give it
some new options so they're not gonna
completely try and reinvent the wheel
which maybe that'll actually help them
get more re-issues going if they need to
but on the other side
if you didn't get what you wanted before
you might be able to still have to go
after a good one but on the other side
it's not gonna just totally suck when
they bring back weapons so i think this
was to sum that up i think that's
generally a good thing anybody have any
thoughts on that piece before we get
into all the crazy archetypes
hmm
do i have i mean um paddy gets i'm just
glad to see them doing something like
this i think that
bringing back weapons that used to have
a good role and you can't get it anymore
is really frustrating so anything that
they can do i mean like i just said the
if soul one is the biggest example that
comes to mind is like i lit i would do
anything in the game i could to get
snapchat opening shot i think that's the
best role but you can't get it right now
so it's like in any situation like that
that they can prevent while still also
opening up you know new roles with new
perks now the one thing i will say about
that is i don't want them to go too
crazy with it because having like the 12
perks in a single column
that's so annoying because like the odds
of actually ever getting what you want
are so slim but it's like i feel like
they go too far in that direction so i
hope they keep it reasonable i think
like seven or so is okay but i mean but
getting what you want out of 12 is like
pretty rough bottom dollar was like oh
you might get one in your entire game
but reset and your only one you got was
complete garbage because your odds are
160 000 or something stupid so i agree
trav
evil genius look what's going on
oh sorry i'm still thinking about
combination that's just all he's like
he's in the lab
i'm like i'm probably not gonna play
like this weekend because
on toilet but i'm already like kind of
you already scavenged i love it i love
your scheme and yeah i love it that
that's the sandbox for douche i love
when you you sit there you start
thinking of combinations you start
thinking about to do better it's the
greatest thing that that's why i've been
suckers to say about i think titans are
going to benefit from this more than
other classes because they have so many
exotics that are about like
refreshing your ammo reserves and the
problem has always been that eventually
you run out of that pool but like yeah
like auto rifles machine guns especially
what machine guns are getting oh man
that's crazy right now acting rig i'm
gonna be pulling that sucker out for
sure maybe that's why when you were all
complaining about the titans not getting
much love because intrinsically you guys
have a ton of
ammo dealing
non-reloading
type of cities it took us seven years to
get here so let's see how it goes
i actually think titans probably don't
get
buffed or debuffed a lot because they're
kind of in a good place
like people who play titans like them
and they're they you know
they're just not they're not very like
controversial
relax and hunters always have some
controversy going on with your subclass
like oh yeah
like chaos reach is super overpowered or
something like the hunters
titans are just like kind of barely
doing this little bob and weave and you
guys are getting the extreme scales this
is busted bring it down this is busted
bring it down this was busted bring it
back up like there's a roller coaster
that goes on with some of the classes
the stasis titan was pretty strong
this is the most busted class i've ever
seen this class gets the lit probably i
said this i gotta ride for my man
citizen he's a hunting champion right
now this is the most
class
the most
they wait so long before a titan
situation gets nerfed one eyed magician
soon as you heard the clank of that
thing you ran for the don't give me this
oh it takes you so
it takes so long yeah
and the stasis one like all of them were
broken yeah everybody says this was
busted
that's like that's like that was like
vegas shattered
that you know what i mean like
stasis
can shut down a super the the the
roaming test
zoe in chat she's forever i got zoe i
got irl titan we got back up
a season of terror
you guys have expansions of terror you
guys have years of terrorizing other
classes
but here's the thing
the the terror the terrorism that we've
been putting on you in crucible is
purely based on skill oh my god you have
to rely on broken subclasses
you know what skill you have the
developers
[Laughter]
in season three titans getting around at
mach 10 and punching everybody
thank you patty thank you patty for the
resources
for balance we don't have enough mobiles
yeah
all right right over
yeah that was fun that's what we do
though we get distracted things go long
hashtag we're gonna stay on task because
it's a long twist
man
he got me the bite this time i normally
don't bite damn it travis is the the
epitome of a button pusher over here oh
my god you're so good at it too oh
archetypes we got some changes so this
is gonna be one big time stamp section
i'm not gonna break this one up too much
i'm gonna cover the first one because i
think it's the one everybody's been
waiting for as of recent switches
breach grenade launchers are increasing
as a pain point in pvp
with um and with the shotgun nerf we're
seeing a small increase in usage this
change aims to reduce the ease of
getting big splash damage for priming or
cleaning up targets
we'll watch and see how things change
and make further adjustments in a future
update if needed
they reduce the blast damage
basically by a little bit from max and
minimum they reduce the splash damage by
20. uh they increase the damage in pve
by 12 that's actually kind of cool uh
because of the above splash damage this
results in a small overall buff to
combine damage and the wither horde
not in the mix um
patty i wanted to ask you on the high
level with regards to breech loads
especially
uh people probably hate when i use mine
because i actually have some fun with
mine
um but you're probably also like oh god
you're one of those aren't you uh so
thoughts on breach loads from you sir
i've been so like i have hated grenade
launchers forever like literally since
the beginning of destiny 2 but i have
over the last season like i recognized
that they were becoming i think probably
the best special weapon they're just
they're so powerful and you can use them
in so many different ways you can get
one that kills with them you can hit
people around cover you can use them as
a primer to weaken someone in him one
shot of dmt or you know auto rifle or
handcannon whatever and so i've been
experimenting with them a lot i'm i
think this direction this is going in
the right direction for nerfing them but
i am i don't think it's enough probably
i mean who knows we'll see like when we
actually play it but
i was hoping to see a little bit even
more of a reduction in the radius of the
blast specifically so that because it
talked about like the identity of them
being potentially like a skill shot
where you have to like you know maybe
bounce off a corner and land it really
close to someone i feel like right now
it's just too generous for the blast
radius i think that it needs to be
ultimately i'd like to see them make it
so you have to be a lot closer to the
target when it explodes and so i i feel
like this is going in the right
direction but maybe
we'll see i don't i
i don't think this will nerf them that
strongly
yeah the uh the whole it has to be a
precision weapon but it's a weapon that
the main way you hurt somebody is
through splash damage like area damage
is like wait what
it's supposed to be a pursuit like
that's what snipers are for what are you
talking about yeah i just think uh if if
the one one or two things needs to
change either the splash damage needs to
come way down to make it more like a
precision weapon or what i think they
should do is keep the splash damage and
just make it do less damage like it just
it takes your whole shield down it i
think it just does way too much damage
because like it shouldn't be doing more
than a sniper rifle that doesn't hit you
in the head and i think that's one of
those
that they've been having trouble finding
their identity is that they there's this
like rule that all special weapons need
to be able to one hit kill
right which i understand because it's
like they want parody between them but
then it's like grenade launchers
how do you justify that that it's like
it's both this super generous thing that
bounces around walls and is is you know
literally uh imagine having your hunter
grenade every you know a few seconds
that you can keep throwing it's very
strong
um but at the same time it's like it
needs to be strong enough they can one
hit kill i feel like they need to like
potentially abandon that role for
grenade launchers
or make it like you said a precision
weapon you have to hit them very
directly like one of the two
yeah i think they should do the former i
i don't think that all special weapons
should because it's like a sniper rifle
you can bounce around corners and and
that explodes when it hits its point of
contact like there's just no way to
balance that in the meadow like you have
to you have to pick a road i think they
should just make it a uh okay my special
weapon isn't going to one hit kill but
it is going to be super versatile and be
able to bounce around corners and have a
more generous splash radius it should
sort of be like the easy mode special
weapon you know they also benefit really
they benefit greatly from like damage
buffs so for example like the charge
with light system if you have like that
with a proxy grenade launcher you can
then it's like a really easy one hit and
so i feel like that oh yeah that's you
know it's like they they benefit more
than i think a lot of special weapons do
with that extra damage because all of a
sudden it turns what would have been
like in almost one hit into a one hit
right even if they're not very close
yeah i mean i'm just thinking about
right now my god rolled uh ignition code
at pve i'm just curious so see how i was
yeah that's the thing is i was like i
just want to make sure they don't lose
their fun in pve because salvador salvo
for add clear with the explosion pve is
where i enjoy pvp i don't play that much
but i understand like their worry and
this is where again the separate sandbox
tuning and stuff like that hopefully you
know one doesn't reduce the fun of the
other they said they increased the
damage but now if like the explosion
radius isn't as big
[Music]
i'm worried because i'm worried about
missing shots and people now thankfully
i got a slideshot roll with mine
but you know it it's that reload thing
and you just i just want to see how that
plays out if it's so not generous with
the splash damage in pve
now in pvp you know yeah we got to see
you know to to patty cake's point is it
truly
going to be enough where it's it's not
going to be oppressive because yeah like
the cleanup on that thing is it's beast
man and then you talk a one-hit kill
potential
you know it's it's a very versatile
weapon that like you said the uptime is
pretty high
you know
it's it i think it's something they're
going to continue to look at but i'm not
convinced this is the end-all be-all to
fix breach
kind of thing that's where i'm at
it's fair uh pretty straightforward one
next machine guns twenty percent pde
save baby
what's up
if you're listening to this in audio cog
is doing the happy dance right now
what's up sir what are you what are you
looking forward to using
i got some i got some i got some um
let's talk about the 450s i haven't used
450s in a while so i'm thinking about
that commemoration from the from the
raid you know with those reconstruction
perks going on yeah you know what i'm
saying i'm thinking about good old
thunderlord baby we need some
thunderlords yes i miss it miss it we're
going to talk about the
in a minute but it's still there yeah
it's still there it's there but we're
gonna get into it with the notes that
you'll see but i'm just thinking about
legendary machine especially um
what was the one it was a even though
it's uh sunset the archetype it was a
gamer head
it was a get gambit
oh 22 or 21 delirium or something right
but what archetype was that was like a
900 it was crazy 500. i want to see how
the different archetypes do
you know with the 900s i'm sitting on
some some really sick rolls from beyond
light those the ones that little orange
i mean that was kind of blue and yeah
they've been already yep yeah that would
be like they're the ones that like
feather the shots everywhere they don't
feel as like chomps
it's almost like a flamethrower like
yeah but it's not an accurate god those
are annoying yeah yeah yeah those are
slower that i can at least point in the
right direction yeah but i'm curious and
the um the one and the one i'm really
curious is the i think it's the high
impact framework the 360s or i forgot
which which one those are but i want to
see how the difference is pretty slow i
know i forget what it is
i think it's in that archetype yeah yeah
i'm curious to see which archetype comes
out on top or if it's just you know the
the high damage i mean the uh the ones
the 450s end up
you know kind of ruling i wonder which
one are the archetypes going to rule
with this that's what i'm curious about
let's
all it does is change the uh damage
across the board right so it'll probably
just be the exact same ones that are
dominating now we'll continue to
dominate they'll just do more damage but
it's just this thing we've it's just one
of those like
where we joke about like bungie's like
shifting the meta on their terms and
when they want to because how long have
machine guns been asked for oh god
couple years now be like oh here's your
20 and be like
we all know we've needed this like
30 on rocket launchers or after like
three years later it's like you guys are
doing this when you want to because we
all know it's been there so
that's just one of those very
intentional like here's a new meta
because we want you to have it type
thing yes agreed uh scout rifles in
handcuffs i want to see what you guys
think scout rifles and hand cams felt
weaker than they'd like in pve in hard
pd content for a while increased damage
versus miners by 15 percent
thoughts
seems fair is it cool with this yeah
do would you want it on others besides
miners or is it just the red bars you
think it sucks on
i really don't think it it needs it
because
you the expectation when you're shooting
a major or boss is that you're not gonna
kill it one hit no matter what weapon
you're using oh of course not unless you
have a special weapon that's super
optimized but
uh yeah like the problem with scout
rifles and hand cannons is
having to shoot something twice with a
hand cannon is way more time than it
takes for you know an smg to shoot
something or whatever uh and so yeah i
think if this gets you over the
threshold where you're like one tapping
acolytes and uh you know some of the
weaker nights and stuff like that would
be that'd be awesome yeah yeah i'm
thinking about uh vandals yeah yeah like
180s i want to know what's going on
because i'm like some of those some of
those 180s i have are really really good
roles and i it's just frustrating just
going in and the red bar is still
standing after you shoot it two or three
times i mean what about you patty casey
what any particular scouts or um hand
cannons that you're thinking about well
the first one that comes to mind for me
is fatebringer if they bring all this
stuff because i mean that going back to
d1 like that's
my favorite thing in pve is just you
know shooting at one room and everyone
blows up with
firefighters oh yeah yeah amazing so i
mean maybe this will enable a little bit
more of that
i'm a fan of this i i feel like i try to
remember exactly when they
made this nerf quite a while ago now
where they reduce primary weapon damage
and yeah i didn't like it back then so
i'm i'm happy that i bring it back the
other direction i just i think that
shooting
it's kind of like the division like the
bullet sponge effect where just
like shooting things that look weak a
lot of times doesn't feel good
so yeah
i'm my guy right here it's my guy right
here right here that's right nobody
wants to shoot the guy with the hoodie
15 times it doesn't feel good yeah i
know that's yeah but like two kind of
had those little armor breakoff points
but i was like dude i'm still in reality
it's like you only have so much and i've
unloaded like 60 clips over here how
much you got like this has got to stop
so no i completely get that one
uh scouting and hand cannons for ue that
uh
uh fate bringer does sound like a decent
one i have like the role for fatebringer
i got it just normally thank god for
luck but um i mean just things like you
know plucking away let night watch with
stuff a little far away things like a
couple scouts that i've got a good roll
or two on those are just going to feel a
bit better when you're going through
pretty much anything so
overall i would say
just kind of pull out and check with
some but i mean every so often when
like this was a season for scout rifles
and now they're not going to be there
like scout rifles and hand cannons hey
we buffed them you're not going to need
them next season for any champions but
you know it's fine we'll get back to
that later
so
for now yeah just nice to know that
they'll be good
this is a mouthful and a half and it's
the one on fusion rifles it's a big boy
they are getting a massive change
uh they said they've been indirectly
benefited from the mid season 14 shotgun
nerf uh but they want to make the
sub-families of fusion rifles different
um
so they said they've evaluated some
other options they said they wanted to
try like giving projectiles travel time
uh they said they didn't like the idea
of this behavior in destiny 1 but on
investigation found that there are
networking issues with firing rapid
bursts into non-hit scan weapons so
technical nature there burst rate of
fire which i don't know quite what that
implies for a fusion rifle i said this
one they talked about like how it comes
out of oh
like almost in like little chains got it
yeah i believe that's what they're
talking about yeah this would have been
touching design data and audio for every
fusion rifle we've ever shipped
well beyond the scope of what we wanted
for this stage well too much too much
so
increase the pve damage bonus such that
all sub families have a 15 pve bonus
they said previously high impact was 0
precision was 10 rapid fire was 12. so
everybody gets a buff sounds like high
impact is getting the biggest buff in
pve so busted out those high impacts for
a bit more of a wall up onto your
enemies and then they said they pushed
the subfamilies farther apart adjusting
charge time shots fired per burst uh
basically all fusion rifles previously
fired seven
shots and now they've actually kind of
changed that up high impacts are gonna
fire five uh the precision adaptives
they're gonna stick with seven and then
the rapid fires are actually gonna fire
nine and i guess they're adjusting the
balance and everything as well so high
impacts have a base charge time of one
second
precision adaptives are staying mostly
kind of how you expect them to be rapid
fires are going from point five four to
point four six so before i go any
farther so we've got multiple different
shots uh they said they reduced the
total damage per burst on the high
impact ones they increased the total
damage per person on the rapid fire
there's a lot of nuance in here if you
guys want to read the details on this
one but as obviously the hosts have read
all this stuff
um patty specifically is you're very
good at breaking down tier lists and
understanding what needs to be where and
things of the science of these weapons
when you looked over all of this um
fusion rifle change where did you land
when you got done with it
well so and to be honest i don't use
fusions a whole lot in pvp and d2 i
actually did in d1 but they just haven't
called me the same way in d2 um when i
have used them it seemed like the higher
impact ones were just pretty much the
go-to thing and i think what this is
really trying to do is make it so
there's you know a little bit more
choice here where it's like not just you
know one or two fusions that everyone
goes for so i'm excited to see how this
plays out i feel like this is the type
of thing that it's hard to know on paper
like you have to kind of like get in
there and really see which ones feel
good and the complicated thing about
fusions is that there's like different
like you know amounts of bolts that need
to hit for different break points of
like resilience levels and like you know
different the charge time if that you
know increases or decreases the damage
so there's like a lot of little you know
finesse in there but i think this is a
cool system i'm curious to see how they
actually feel in pvp i've been wanting
to spend a little bit more time with
them so i think it's an interesting
change
chance what about you guys
trav would you think fusions
yeah um
fusions have been my favorite weapon
type and destiny forever
i remember
yeah i know and i and the messed up
thing is that the game like
sort of forces you to not use them in
like most situations like they're rarely
the best choice in pve no they're
terrible
yeah um yeah they're really bad um
except for telesto
and in pvp you sort of have to go to
your way to do it i remember when d1
came out
i was getting really sweaty and pvp like
that like right at that first couple
weeks and i went to the office uh the
ign office at the time and and was like
talking about like how my loadout and
comparing notes oh yeah obviously you
got an auto rifle because those are op
when d1 came out and i said i was using
a fusion rifle i was like i love fusion
rifles all my load has that and one guy
looked at me and he was just like
why like why would you do that
i had this really long discussion and he
sort of convinced me obviously he was
right but it was like fusion rifles are
just shotguns that you have to like
prepare earlier and like do a charge
time and you sort of have to be like
like yeah they do more damage and are
more accurate but you sort of have to
have like precognition to use them like
so super effective why would you do that
when you could just shoot somebody with
a shotgun on the face and they die right
away and i don't think destiny has ever
really gotten past that logic like
that's kind of true it's like why would
you ever use a fusion rifle but there's
some certain situations where you could
use it but you sort of have to build
your whole pve pvp build around it like
backing up and getting that shot off
before you get you know aped by somebody
and i've sort of
given in to just using shotguns because
it's the meta and it's been the meta
forever
um right now i'm using i'm using um you
know slug shotguns just because that
that to me it makes the most sense uh in
combining efficiency with with precision
uh but i really really have always
wanted them to like take a look at
fusion rifles because it's like the one
of the most unique uh weapon types they
have and i'm just really excited to see
them get some love i i've always thought
fusion rifles have gotten the shortened
to the stick oh yeah
just by virtue of what they do the
charge time and all that stuff like
they've just never sort of been in that
right spot so
i'm i'm hopeful like i agree with what
patty kicks said i don't think we're
going to really understand this until we
see it in game but it's good to see so
much dedicated to that subclass of
weapons because like gosh does it really
need it man it's really just it for a
long time it's funny they remember back
like i guess it was probably a couple of
years ago now that um aaron till was
like so good it could map people from
like 50 meters i have so many clips of
you just letting a few bolts and then
they got that big nerf because people
are complaining about it and it's like
fusion since then have just been you
know not many people using them but
actually that was funny one of the
things from the vault of glass i was
most disappointed about was they didn't
bring back the praetorian form
i love that
so
i was kind of bummed but i'm you know
interested to see what
what gets popular
yeah and vex smith the class sort of i
mean we're gonna we'll talk about that
later
that's gonna be a whole different weapon
yeah
sort of a victim of the fusion situation
as well i'm i'm totally with you travis
like
i just fell in love with fusions in d1
and no one used them
and i remember getting plan c and you
know just going crazy and i was really
effective with it i used it i used it
more in counter play keep keeps i was
not to be honest i've never been
until fell winter came out
i've never been historically a good
shotgunate for whatever reason when i
go up and rush you know finish the kill
i just just my technique was bad
whatever i was doing it just didn't work
i always felt i got one hit killed but i
could never do that to anyone so i fell
in love with fusions because my
backpedal game when i see the eights and
then i voop them and get them out and
like you said i would kind of have to
pre-plan it's that cognitive
pre-planning all right charging up
before the corner you know whatever just
anticipation kind of thing so like you
know patty said aaron till was my baby
for a while everybody knew that god roll
i was out i was lacing with it man i
really enjoyed it so to see and in pve i
love him too i mean when um loaded
question was in its hey obviously now we
got a plug and we got no composure
i want to see what the distinctions how
much the distinctions between each
fusion class is going to be with the
rapid fires and the adaptives that's
going to be interesting to me but um
shout out to senator yeah a lot of
wolves you know i'm different bro i
always use the anti-meta and he knows
i'm good with lord nobody used that gun
before now to use it a little bit now
but anyway back on point fusion's
excited me i'm i'm glad they are getting
attention and detail this is long
overdue remember trav i can remember in
d1
you could go
like i think i maybe went a whole year
of twabs
and never a mention when it came to
sandbox updates of like they act like
the class didn't even exist like
everybody else's we're getting ten
percent we're getting five we're getting
we're getting point zero four percent on
automatically and i'm like yo fusions
are in the game bungie can you at least
address this this step child of a weapon
class that you don't want to talk about
only the only time fusions get mentioned
is when one of these exotic accents oh
merciless merciless celestial
um basically turned off but because it
broke the game what do you guys will say
it is eve
but i mean you could make it because
they're not sun setting and so
zero damage and it would still have a
role for breaking things so i i don't
think there's a fix there to ease
defense one thing going for him for
exotic sunsetting which he wants is to
leicester oh yeah i would love to see
that one thing budgie would love to get
rid of can
even if it did zero damage though you
could still use it to break things
somebody's like there's really no way
out of it somebody's like telescope's
gonna one-shot champions day one next
season and be like
it's gonna be an interesting one um yeah
yeah also due to all these changes
there's quite a few perks that had to
change on account of the way they
changed the functionality of the weapons
uh they said backup plan they removed
the plus one to 100 that charge time and
they adjusted the charge time multiplier
basically charge time and impact which
is their damage are linked when it comes
to fusion rifles so when one thing is
affected it changes the others so they
had to kind of go through and adjust
perks you have liquid coils and
accelerated coils one hits harder one
charges faster they had to adjust what
it affected as its only charge time as
opposed to charge and impact so they
went through and adjusted quite a bit of
these
there's a bit of detail on the adept
charge time mod um
does anybody even like know much on that
adept charge time mod because i'm going
to be talking pretty cluelessly on that
one
yeah i don't even got one so i just i'm
deferring patty patty i have it
i don't think i've ever used it on
anything but i do own it so
hey you're better than me yeah because
why why would you why would you worry
about the mods for like an irrelevant
class of weapons like yeah
there's not a whole lot you can do with
this plug one and exiles curtis i think
you're probably the only two that yeah
put it on right now so
it's just not a class of weapons i've
really put much time into in the first
place but it'll be interesting to see i
mean like you said i think that the it's
that the way that the damage scales with
the um with the charge time is really
interesting and i think that's kind of
the whole goal of this is to balance it
out so it was there's not such a you
know a one clear you know archetype
that's the best so yeah it'll be
interesting to see like which ones
become popular
especially the next point e i'm very
curious about that this whole masterwork
part
the charge time oh yeah so
they said a note on the charge time
master work
itself uh fusion rifles damaged is
determined by its charge time stat
similar to how most other weapons damage
is determined by the rate of fire
masterworks can only increase weapon
stats for performance reasons so it's
not possible to change how charge time
maps onto damage without big changes to
how the charge time stat works
so they're investigated doing this by
making the masterworks a perk but that
would cause fusion rifles to exceed the
perk budget resulting in bad things
happening remember this is the technical
limitation that
you know engine hopefully ever maybe
probably not
uh with the fusion rifle rework we feel
that this masterwork is more viable uh
it now rarely reduces bolts to kill so
it may feel not
so this was weird or weird when i read
it before yeah so mayfield not
feel like i don't think that's written
yeah
they're just basically saying you know
like a lot like for example um
accelerated coils in the past would be
bad because it would make it it would
charge a little bit faster it took a
whole extra bolt to kill which is a huge
problem on a fusion rifle that's like
makes it much harder to land the one it
kills so yeah that's just what they're
saying is that um you know this
hopefully i guess when using that won't
make it so that you're gonna like step
down to a whole nother being required i
think that's the whole goal with it
got you uh so yeah they just changed up
the fusion rifle stat order apparently
the order of the stats listed on the
weapons wasn't the same as everything
else for some reason fusion rifles sound
like they've been neglected so finally
somebody's like
fusion rifles please and apparently it
got like a focused team so they they
went big on it
um
i said the big change in fusion rifles
including all exotic fusion so we'll be
watching for any major issues
over under on like five days for telesco
to break something but we'll see if it's
any faster than that
all right
now
more fun stuff we had armor last week
this week we have
weapons because exotic weapons obviously
fall into the world of weapon of a
weapon swab
the first one
pour one out everybody hope you enjoyed
your time with it
anarchy
two main things that reduced the total
reserve plus magazine ammo from 26 to 16
and the reserve plus ammo that's if
you're wearing the mods i think is the
way that's written and the reduced
damage by 30
versus bosses but champions are not
bosses
all right i actually think those those
those debuffs are perfect
the two biggest problems anarchy's
always had way too much ammo for that
gun like it just it's never made sense
it's one of the reasons it's been so
strong and specifically it's broken
against bosses it's just the standard
go-to for melting bosses so i actually
think these are like the perfect way to
debuff it without completely
invalidating it it'll still do as much
damage as it always did it'll still be
good at clearing ads and killing
champions and that sort of stuff it just
won't be
you know the go-to actually it's not
even go to it's basically mandatory yeah
the mandatory weapon to to kill uh to
kill um bosses i think it says a lot
that uh the common way to use it is to
like make a little fence around every
door as your dps weapon and then also
use it on the box right yeah yeah
like in most other mmos i think you'd
probably be uh you know saving it for
pure boss damage exactly it's like it's
good for boss damage and clears it's
great for solo like anybody who does
like gm solo most of the time i ever
check anybody out running that they're
always
running this always because it's just
like big big and just like hang out and
hide which again is a whole discussion
over gm's and you know soloing all that
fun stuff but
yeah the whole idea of just
it i think they managed it without
killing it which i'm actually kind of
impressed that they only did
only these two and i'm sure they'll
watch it but i think this is
definitely going to change when and
where it's used because you're not just
gonna go
between the quick swapping and this that
whole methodology is kind of
kind of over it seems like because the
quit swapping and anarchy like throw a
couple on there and then do your quick
swaps they got they kind of nerfed all
three of those pieces of it so that was
seemed like a big focus of what they're
going for
yeah i mean it was the perfect weapon
for every scenario like it literally
could do so much and then with the
breaching clear meta they knew they gave
us our fight oh you know this is the
yeah we do it i to be honest with you
brutally honest
i can't recall a situation
ever running out of like anarchy ammo
like yo i'm low
like like i don't really recall those
situations especially those scavengers i
mean it was now the 30 percent boss boss
is gonna hurt some you know but listen
they're gonna protect the game you know
at the end of the day when this is like
travis you said it perfectly like when
this is the de facto
weapon to use for end game
it was gonna come it was only a matter
of time it's still gonna be good i love
that champions are not going to be
affected you know you still could you
know do your damage there and and jams
and stuff but the days of loading this
up for and and you know six people in a
raid and yeah in the great it's over
four went out for the homie it was a
good run it was a good run man it was
you know hey we have fun but it's still
it's still gonna be effective just not
as dominant as we known it before
uh
yeah i was like me i don't even use the
damn thing because i do videos with
legendaries only because i'm like hey i
know not everybody has the weapon now
you don't have to worry about it so good
stuff absolutely uh xenophage already
top-notch and i'm surprised they
actually didn't kill it because i
thought it was gonna get a little worse
so they said they reduced the rate of
fire from 120 to 90
but it received less of the machine gun
damage buff so in general they said the
damage per bullet is going to be bigger
but it's going to be
basically result in slightly lower
damage per second but higher burst and
sustained damage so it's
kind of their way to slow it down but
still keep it you know relevant like if
you put a single shot into something
it's still going to hit like a truck
but it's not going to be quite as
dominant it seems i think they were
trying to make sure the machine gun buff
didn't
yeah
yeah this is what it went through they
knew this was going to go through zeno
been
i'll jump in obviously but yeah zeno's
been been it's been a terror like gino
is he knows that that that weapon you
know what i'm saying so
i totally was like oh yeah is this going
to be the rain that is it they had to
pull it back that rate of fire i almost
think of like um
i don't know it's not as extreme but i
always think of like leviathan's breath
you know like how hard it hits but that
pulled time right that that that dps for
that bull is going to take a while so
effectively during the damage phase
you're not going to be able to get a
zillion of these shots off as you could
in the past and i think that's what it
is they want to bring that rate of fire
down so that it's not constantly pumping
out that high damage so fast so i i mean
it's fair i think but what do you guys
think
yeah i think xeno is the reason that you
don't see really sniper busts dps
anymore like why would you it does as
much damage it shoots faster you don't
have to aim it as hard like
i i think this might actually see
possibly i mean snipers are not in a
great place snipers need a buff against
yes but yeah i could see i could see a
sniper strap being more viable now that
xeno isn't going to be as
as dominant but yeah
i'm really curious to see how this
actually impacts it in pvp just because
this
i mean
120 to 90 rpm is a pretty giant rate of
fire change and i'm not sure off the top
of my head what like the base damage
does um for like a a single shot in like
regular pvp but
i'm trying to think it's either a nerf
or a buff and i'm not sure yeah i have
to figure out that i haven't used it for
a minute but um yeah it'd be interesting
so i remember i feel like xeno i used to
use it in pvp i still think it's two
shots
one shot
cause if if it's still it was a one shot
to the body i think right i'm trying to
remember and if if so then it's a nerf
to the gun right because it's gonna
shoot slower so right but correct maybe
be better against supers or something
who knows but yeah it'll be interesting
to see
shout out to the sleeper simulator boys
feel things coming on
i feel thanks coming down for the
sleeper
every week we gotta hear him talk about
sleeper stimulus that's right the rise
to the top it's been a long road
that's a great gun it's like the only
it's the only gun that's ever been a
fusion rifle that's been like an
essential part of the meta for a while
yeah
fighting lion
they mentioned has been fun but not
dominant in pvp so we weren't worried
about
uh impacting the infinite ammo there
however enabling fast unlimited grenades
was going to be a problem in pvp
um so basically they said it's taking
its ammo from a lot to infinite so it
actually is still going to have infinite
ammo receive the same changes as other
grenade launchers that we mentioned
above they said the reduce the base
reload stat to zero meaning it will
reload very
very slowly but they increased now
increases reload speed to its previous
level on damaging multiple enemies with
one grenade
so kind of the perk that it has you'll
know is kind of be back there pretty
quick
uh we'll be keeping an eye on this one
you shouldn't be manually reloading
basically fighting lion as it is uh but
it will be getting infinite ammo so if
you take fighting line and pvp well you
can avoid grenade launcher just going
ham forever
well it will be interesting if that one
gets to be a little bit of fun vex
mythoclast
the first line tells it all i don't even
know if i need to read the rest of them
pve damage bonus of 40 percent
40.
they said they were combined
they said we were oh you got it damn
fast oh yeah man i'm ready i'm ready yo
soon we're gonna get that catalyst
tonight let's go baby whoa continue so
i've got the catalyst already i'm ready
to go oh i helped fall out make that
godless video but i don't even have the
damn gun so you guys have fun
sorry buddy
yeah i got it that first week and i got
the catalyst as soon as i got the the
gun so i got it i just i used it in pve
and i was like wow this isn't that good
and then i used it in pvp and i was like
wow this is worse
[Laughter]
put it in the vault quick question what
is the steps one quick trap what is this
steps involved you got it is it like
that
it's oh yeah you got it you got to go do
uh the vault of glass and then you have
to uh find certain plates you stand all
like puzzles of shooting oracles and it
is it is pretty uh it uh we had fun
doing it but like i maybe maybe it felt
tedious because i had just got done
doing vaulted glasses
yeah
okay
yeah
like it's a
it's similar to the tediousness of the
one from the garden divinity yeah
it's just a little extra one encounter
this one you have to do throughout the
room yeah you got to do like four or
five of these things well you have to do
that you're right you have to do like a
little puzzle each time yeah the only
part that was interesting i actually did
also did it with fallout and we
at the very end there's sort of like a
little kovacs like scenario we have to
keep shooting a whole bunch of them real
fast because you have to shoot the or
were you there with me when i did that
were you and i
i was i think maybe
that sounds familiar because i know the
last one
i shot all seven because i recorded it
for him
gotcha so actually yeah yeah we just did
a run recently so i'm not sure oh it was
when he made the video a long time ago i
was helping him with that but uh
maybe that was for his own account or
something but yeah it was uh it's
interesting it's it's not like i
wouldn't say it's hard but it's just you
know it's tedious doing it after each
thing but you know you only got to do it
once it's not about it it's not that bad
just yeah go watch a video just to get
an idea what you're getting into but
it's really not too bad it's going to be
worth it now probably for sure
preach read the good word continue
without that range that increased to
near best in class for a high impact
auto rifles
so more range increased stability the
rework the catalyst to grant stability
and damage after a kill what does it do
right now
so it gives you uh
the catalyst gives you stacks of
stability on each kill so um
like you know how the the effect works
where you get like up to six stacks and
you can convert it into the lfr mode
instead so basically each time i think
it gives you additional stacks of
stability so it's only like it's gonna
get damaged now too which is damage as
well damage in the lfr mode or how does
that work i don't know if this is in i
don't know if this is in place of the of
the stacks where if it's like just after
a kill like it's like a rampage type
thing or however
this is going to work it feels like a
rampage standing because it
grant stability and damage after a kill
as far as i know right now it's based on
the number of stacks that you have of
the things it'll be interesting to see
if that's still the case they didn't
they didn't really make this super clear
mm-hmm
the the biggest perk that we're getting
the biggest buff is the last one no
longer loses over charge stats yes so
that is crazy because that that was the
main thing that made that weapon like
not good to you especially in pvp man
like you you have to switch weapons all
the time and that made it so that you
just you you have to stick to it and
switch to the mode and it didn't do
enough damage in pve to be worth all
those kills you got to get before you
can charge it up especially since you
can't change in between you just had to
like
do it
it was it was awful and i was just like
why like is it really that hard to add
like one kilobyte of memory dedicated to
remember
all they gotta do is
they got to do yeah
the armchair developer but still it's
like it just it
it vexed me
somebody somebody clipped that face
right there
i'm excited i think this is the first
gun i'm going to try
the new season i really think this thing
this is literally addressing every
problem i have the vex it had really
crappy range and it was it was a type of
uh auto rifle archetype that would
typically have good range right it's
like the long like the hard-hitting
long-range ones so that's improving it
the stability felt terrible and like it
was just jumping all over the place i
imagine for controllers even worse it
was better
all full of control so like that's
another huge thing i thought the
catalyst was dumb like it just it didn't
make any sense because you would get
stacks of the thing and it would get
more stable but then you wanted to use
the lfr mode so then you'd lose all of
your stacks as soon as it just was like
a weird
thing and there's a cycle of irritation
yeah exactly and then this this lfr
charge time is a huge reduction
i haven't got there that is that makes
it from like kind of a meme thing to
like 533 is like a fat one of the faster
fusion rifle charges like that's not so
bad so
i think this thing could get like really
really powerful with all these changes
yes and the base rate of fire also
increased right the um yeah yeah yeah
360 390 so it's gonna be like probably
the fastest killing uh three you know
360 archetype of auto rifles so and i
don't know if they'll also change the
base damage to like match you know to
change that a little bit or
if they'll keep like the 360 damage
profile while shooting at 390 i don't
know we'll see but what what yeah i
think this thing could be really good
all of a sudden
this is the better this is oh yeah
apparently i gotta go i gotta vault more
now apparently
yeah time to get an airport y'all i'm so
glad
it reminds me of when zeno first came
out and was garbage
everybody was like 50 buff and you're
like really i'm like oh
like this and then the the dual purpose
like that linear fusion switch this is
gonna be
ridiculous i cannot wait i'm gonna get
that catalyst somebody will somebody
check out the video just you can see
that cog is gonna smile through his ears
just just
excited you know how i get with buffs
you know i get i know
i know if sleeper was listed you'd be
just you wouldn't even you'd be not safe
for work right now so it'd be fine
i wonder how a thousand voices is gonna
work with the fusion rifle changes
good point separate conversation i was
actually wondering because i was doing a
breakdown on all the champions
because you've got vex that's gonna be a
unstoppable but i'm like
how is it to work as an unstop is it the
auto rifle part that works in one way is
it the linear you have to use is an
unstoppable
and then thousand voices the same way is
like is it the first tag that gets the
unstoppable and then the explosion does
even more damage you like one shot i
don't know i'm wondering how fusions
work because they are going to be
interesting
yeah
uh i'm going to kind of go through these
three kind of quick merciless yeah they
updated the perk for fewer shots per
burst uh should build up charge rate at
the same time reduce the damage penalty
for increasing the charge rate by 40
percent
um
not bad seems fair yotan uh they reduced
the charge time from 0.82 to 0.78 it's
0.04 seconds faster slightly reduce the
damage per shot seems to just make it
fire a little quicker
bastion i know merciless is going to be
not merciless um
mercury's gonna be sad about this one oh
yeah this is like one of this is like
his baby this is
uh reduced damage by 15 increased the
spread angle by 10
but they did increase the pve damage by
25
kind of an overall increase of about 10
percent on this one
uh basically it was just kind of the
fact that it can the fact that it can
break a titan's
tower shield and then kill them with one
shot is this needed to happen man it was
so so cheesy yeah i'm only sad that i'd
never got the the infamous triple kill
with like you know one one burst
oh man that'd be hard to ever pull it
off again i guess i have a couple more
days to try
yeah not too many of those um
it won't quite one yeah it's like it
won't quite one kill guardian and then
switch because it's gonna be beast it's
gonna be beast and remember it still has
that they just gave it that unstoppable
intrinsic
thing yeah perk with it and on top of
the fusion mod and on top of pve damage
increased by what 25 percent that's
strong in pve pvp not so much but pve is
going to be good
uh sweet business basically they just
had a change for the primary ammo so it
now refills the magazine on picking up
special or heavy instead of primary
basically i had to change it because
they had to
ah you got your street sweet business
chat going you ready are you ready i
think that's gonna be a game changer
it's already kind of making a comeback
and with the infinite ammo thing yeah
if you could fire that thing especially
with um
ryland barricade actually more rig just
oh god
six titans six riley barricades six
sweet business
it's just a spray
tracer rounds in a movie or something
it's just constant bullets with the
boots they auto reload
yeah
disgusting
can be delicious couple perks they want
to change firing line they basically
reduce the damage bonus to 20 precision
damage for all supported weapons
strange but fine uh they said certain
damage perks
affected uh impact damage on explosive
weapons they've updated it also for the
detonation damage kill clip rampage
adrenaline junkie pretty straightforward
stuff there um
they said in the more distant future but
still before witch queen linear fusion
rifles and caster frame swords are still
not where we want them to be
um so expect some tweaks there the
caster frame swords i've toyed around
with those in like a master lost sector
and i got through it was the best though
yeah uh linear fusions though i will say
i've used i was just like hey as a meme
i'm gonna do a couple of videos i'm like
if i can get through this
with a linear fusion rifle on master
difficulty you guys can probably do this
with any of your other tools that are
likely better i'm like i'm sitting there
just getting like a couple crits from
across the map i'm like they're not so
bad
they're not amazing but like depending
on if that's just what you're gonna use
they're not as bad as i thought so
they're they're okay if they get another
buff they definitely could be something
to think about uh they said they're also
looking at underused exotics uh they'll
take a pass at some of them like
herbalists or us regime cryoesthesis
malfeasance and more so weapon exotics
are again going to be on the table to
hopefully be getting some buffs
um
if you have issues with spamming high
rate of fire semi automatic weapons as
fast as possible we've got something for
you what do you guys read into that line
like a full auto mod or something like
you know they've talked about different
mods that they might be adding to like
armor mods and stuff like that doesn't
like a quick draw one or the different
different things that they have hinted
at so
that makes me think that there's
potentially some like armor set up with
it that i don't know i feel like this is
leading us to something that they're
going to talk about somewhat soon but
we'll see yeah
uh they said priming a target and
quickly swapping for cleanup is easier
than we'd like we're looking at options
for building towards faster
uh swap speeds we've got a step for
hitting both of these uh coming so
they've got some stuff they're working
on that one kind of worries me because
that is kind of a really
important part of just like playing
destiny
isn't super fun to have have to wait for
a reload or have to wait for you to
switch weapons so the idea of like
making it harder to do that like
well it's interesting because i mean the
biggest hit to that was fixing the quick
draw glitch right you can do it
instantaneously with that and it's not
really that hard to pull off so it's
like the the fact that you can
you know i don't know it'll be
interesting to see if it's kind of like
taking it away as a glitch but making it
build into it maybe so i don't know this
is like that time they said they were
increasing reload times across the board
and i was like oh so they want us to
spend more time waiting to play the game
like it's like saying oh i'm going to
increase load times into new areas
buff to load times it's like why like
who does that help just make everybody
faster i like like doom like doom was
perfect for me doom and doo maternal
like there's no reloading of any weapons
like that's how all games should be but
anyway
um they said they also previously talked
about wanting legendary weapons to have
more identity based on their source and
expect to ship a new system for this in
or close to witch queen
in season 15 we tweaked exotic primary
weapons to generate ammo faster through
ammo finder mods and have another change
played to make them more enticing in
hard pve content again these exotic
primaries they're really a focus for
them right now
um
that's all we've got for weapon changes
for now we're looking forward to seeing
how the pve and pvp meta shape up so
overall lots of weapon changes coming
basically jump in new sandbox if you've
got a vex you may be in love we'll just
have to see how that one plays out cog
will have to sometimes wipe that smile
off his face but not right now cause
it's plastered there
uh but even more guns they said most of
everything the season of the redacted
everything's gonna happen on the 24th we
talked about this and they just keep
conv we don't know squat but we do have
season of the us
pretty much um
but we do have the new ritual weapon it
is going to be a rocket launcher with
explosive light
anybody want to remind chat what
explosive light is because i'm blinking
actually when you collect orbs it does
more damage i wasn't uh when to go i
think
yeah yeah that's right
um as
as is the custom you can collect a
gambit crucible vanguard and then get
your ornaments later on actually there's
a pretty cool look to it though i like
it i like the look really aesthetically
yeah i like it yeah the front of that
barrel looks pretty sweet
now they also said they're adding three
weapons as post-game awards for
completing strikes gambit crucible so
you've got what looks to be like a
gambit sniper maybe a crucible
soros what is that maybe an auto i think
it's a scout rifle
it looks like it looks wz
right yeah isn't that
i used to like that
yeah what was the name of that one
what's the name of it kind of reminds me
of noah and beyond
damn look i used to like that scout that
was i didn't see vanilla scout and you
get it from
and vanilla doesn't yeah i used to love
that scout it's from devrin it was it
was good at the time i can't remember
the name of it right now and then it
also looks like a little baby sidearm on
the end
i think the one that i saw
looks like a 600 i'm hoping that otto's
kind of something like remember like the
galley yard
a good roll but that thing was so good
even even just with the bad rolls fatty
cakes i'm wishing bro yeah i had that
galley on two six it was good man 600
yeah those weapons were hard to find
that the weapons i missed from that
was that one and the um
the hand cannon that could run roll kill
the ripper
those black army references were sick
but yeah that's what that's spicy
mm-hmm oh kill uh what is it kindled
orchid or dude or something yeah yeah
yeah
well the auto rifle is even harder cause
that was that was one that just it
didn't have a direct farmable way it
just dropped randomly from those bosses
and stuff so yeah i don't know that i'd
actually be pretty excited if they
brought that back i like that gun yeah
me too i think one of the popular ones
that i saw on twitter is the next one
they're giving the prophecy dungeon some
new purpose because they're putting the
trials of the nine one two three four
five six weapons
into the prophecy dungeons some will be
dropping at certain encounters uh it's
one thing a lot of people aren't asking
for because it is like of the nine the
whole crazy place that it's at so now
all these weapons that have been sending
out there are coming back i really never
had any of these weapons so this will be
kind of fun to get these messages
i had all of these auto rifles so fun
yeah the auto sniper was great the uh
both pulses really cool darkest before
was my favorite pulse back in the day so
i'm really excited for these i love the
aesthetics and the aesthetic is cool
when i go from that's cool they're
coming back with random rolls down too
cause like for example maybe the sniper
can get like snapshot which that's been
that'd be cool
yeah i missed trials of the nine trouser
nine stands unite and it's like if you
if you see patty in a long range map
leave the game by the way just don't
watch this guy sniping he will just you
won't even see him your head will just
be gone
but it is nice to see um these weapons
that a lot of people never even got to
see aesthetics always been very cool
it's very fitting they're going in there
it's been a pretty easy ad
on top of all these weapons we're
updating the world loot pool with some
fresh drops here's some new weapons if
you guys are looking at those the only
one that i specifically recognize is the
um
it's the vice scout rifle and i can't
remember the name of it
that one specifically
mm-hmm what else do you guys remember
that new monarchy yeah
hand cannon i can't remember a little
baby vanguard sidearm coupled gambit it
looks like maybe by the green these must
be all the uh faction weapons they left
behind when they left the planet
seems like it right seems like a lot of
action stuff yeah
when when all three factions got
destroyed off screen
yeah did you ever have faction rallies
or affection or just faction rallies are
no longer factions are no more
mm-hmm
narratively written out the game love it
that was kind of funny
that's hilarious
no more weapons in the wild we like that
yeah so i mean the pool keeps building
more stuff's going to be there obviously
nothing is ever sunset so i'll just kind
of be curious if we ever get to the
point where like the world loot pool has
400 weapons
now we have to sunset stuff again
because there's too much
last week's 12 was a c minus for me this
is an a there you go like this 12 is
great it does so much right and and it
actually makes last week's 12 a little
better too because now i'm understanding
some of their logic with some of the
buffs and yeah i think uh i think this
is an awesome 12. they should have put
this one first
in my opinion
yeah
so we get some new guns but there's also
a lot of reissues in here people are you
know chat saying new red it's like
that's a lot of reissued guns
some new perks some will be fresh for a
lot of people and it depends like i mean
when you go through and make videos for
content you're like oh man i've been i'm
pretty new to the game i'm jumping in
i'm like should i be excited and you're
going
sure yeah you've got a whole lot of
stuff to look forward to us you've been
around for seven years you like you know
some new roles some new perks things
that you can use again are good but also
on the some side it is still they're
working the reissues which i think it's
just putting more and more like
and if they're doing the reissues now
and which queen is even better for it
i'm totally fine with it at this point i
think
um i have to say i feel like i'm more
excited like i've been a little jaded
about destiny lately honestly just
because i i've been like you said
playing for seven years like not that
much is changing but i'm actually really
excited about this new season now it's
like i think that they're doing a lot of
smart things in the sandbox to emphasize
more primary fights for pvp
i think the pve will be interesting with
a lot of new weapons to try out and
different things that they're doing like
that even just the subclass changes are
will be interesting and
you know announcing the anti-cheats a
huge step in the right direction new
trials changes we don't really know much
about yet like
there's actually i think a lot of stuff
to be excited about even just the trials
of the nine weapons coming back like i'm
excited to get some of those again and
try a different role so
i'm i'm more excited i think this season
than i even was the beginning of last
season or you know any of the the
previous ones so i agree i'm with you i
mean
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's a lot of
positive energy in the air i love this
update a lot of things getting addressed
you know
fundamentally then we got the weapon and
then again all of this is still a
precursor
to which queen these are tons of changes
yeah bro it's setting up nicely man
he ain't going he's gonna stop my joy
you ain't gonna stop my hype
i'm excited i ain't tempering no
expectations damn it i'm ready this is a
lot of changes man i'm excited this is
so much and i think travis that what you
said earlier which is
i'm starting the the veil behind the
curtain of the long-term plan
with the weapon archetypes the different
you know um
you know um elements and with stasis and
then maybe a poison class or something
that is rumored right and like we're
starting to see things take shape and to
me stasis represented the new wave of
how they want to do things you know from
a class standpoint and um yeah i mean
anti-cheat is huge y'all that cheat is
huge like these are made and then i
always said even if the season we know
next season is long because which queen
is delayed
cross play is going to be huge with
bringing the community together like
they're setting up man i don't want to i
know that'll get too crazy but i'm
getting hyped again and i'm like yo
yeah they might be back baby they might
be taking king
yeah bungie tends to bring the feet to
like this the seasons right before the
big expansion comes out like if you
think back to opulence like that was a
really good season yeah the one right
before beyond light was a fun season
like they
i feel like they said they tend to save
the bangers season
right before the expansion i'm excited
there's one thing about it i think it's
a it's
really exciting to just to see so much
focus on the sandbox because it's been
neglected i think in favor of just like
pumping out content and letting the
sandbox sort of sort itself out and it
seems like they're really they're really
doing the opposite now and making some
strategic bets and yeah i mean there's
gonna be some stuff that changes and and
you know we're gonna you know people
like pattycakes and i are gonna have to
like rework our strategies but you know
as they say can't nerf these hands
bungee
bring it on i say we will adapt and
we'll uh we'll figure it out i gotta ask
e cause i know he he's missed temper
expectations
so like uh is is the hype i see the
tweet sir the tweets from you say
excitement the tweets from you say i
can't wait count down in days oh of
course i'm hyped dude there's no way i'm
not all i'm just saying is they even
said at the end because i actually about
closed it but i want to read the end of
this so you guys are kind of on the same
page here
because season 15 witch queen
this game always has so much potential
to everybody there's always there's
always potential that we see something
even greater behind what we already have
in front of us i've been
worse at that than ever it's like you
know my hope for amazing workings of
armor and stuff i'm like i still don't
think i'm ever gonna see that now maybe
when they describe all the stuff and
when they say it's like the seven years
before when you look at the showcase
website are leading up to where we are
getting to right now it's like the
wording that they're using
is substantial like it's getting to a
point to where like they're they're
doing the hype job so if they don't live
up it's partially on them because they
really are saying like
seven years has been leading up to this
this is like an adventure you've never
been on before
i mean is it just the fact that we're
finally going to face savathun or is it
like is the game going to be just like
crazy changed and they say five more
sleeps until the reveal
you are more than welcome to join us for
the on our main channels but if you want
to co-stream it that's totally fine
we've been hyping this up but at the
same time don't want to over hype
let's let's just say you should expect
at least one video
and someone talking about destiny i've
said too much listen we are excited and
hope you enjoy what we've been cooking
up see you next tuesday
and that's kind of the biggest thing
about it it's always with this game it's
better to keep your expectations in
check
don't be too over hyped
and then at least be surprised for the
positive
i mean think of season of the worthy
that's one of the cooler trailers they
say that bro
expansion time
you know how they do right when their
backs against the wall they they come
through sometimes at the lowest suppose
sometimes you literally just said it
yourself
all i'm saying i have a lot of faith but
i think there's also a lot of weight on
which queen
depending on what people want so
they just got to give you some armor
that's what they if they give you armor
in this complex fashion that you want
then you're going to get what you want
then you're going to be cheering you're
going to be alongside
you give me a dungeon you give me a
dungeon and cool armor yeah i'll
probably go lose my mind on it but it's
like oh yeah
i was like so that's kind of what i
wanted to end on is like what are the
things especially patti since you're the
guest like
season 15 we don't know how long it's
gonna be six seven months something like
that but we also know which queen is
we're gonna see something about it on
tuesday what are you
what do you want to see the most i know
you're pvp guy but i mean story's been
interesting kind of building do you even
care about it like what is your i mean
what's your hope for tuesday
so the thing is i
i definitely play pvp the most like
that's where i spend the most time but i
actually really do enjoy the pve stuff
when there's something new like every
season there's a new raid like i will be
you know raid ready on day one like i i
do all that stuff it's more just that
i'm not the type of person who wants to
run the same raid 100 times like once
i've beaten it a number of times i got
my loot from it then i want to do
something you know that's a little bit
more repeatable and and in other games
like other uh you know eso for example i
did get really hard into the um mmo side
of the game where you're really playing
you know all the the challenging and
game stuff so if if there was more of
that in destiny i would actually get
more into it but um i'm just excited for
you know to see what where they're
bringing this like we've talked about i
feel like there's this game has always
had so much potential there's a reason
that i you know i cover it on my channel
and i've just been so interested in it
for so long i think that just it has so
much potential to potentially
lead up to some really cool things and
i'm excited
what about you guys
tuesday is around the corner this is our
pre
this is our pre-showcase show like what
do you guys want to make any crazy
predictions
is there anything you want to be like
i'm we're going to see this mic drop
what do you guys what are you what are
you two looking for yeah
i guess my prediction is it'll be more
about witch queen than it will be about
season 15.
i think season 15 all things said and
done will be pretty minor and i think we
might not even they might even really
show a lot of it at all on tuesday i
think they because it'll be so close you
know you don't put out a trailer for
a game that or something that you could
play right now it's basically going to
be like on that day right um so
i i think i think it'll be witch queen
focus but i'm sort of in between you and
cog like i definitely am not trying to
keep myself in line but i'm also
there's always that part you know cog
it's like when you're playing like gears
tactics or x-com and you you go to shoot
at a guy and says 85 percent chance and
you start sweating because 85 percent if
you've ever played next con game is like
is like terrible like you're going to
miss 100 of the time
that's sort of what i feel like with
destiny it's like you know we're aiming
on the guy it says 85 hit chance but
it's destiny man there's
there's always a little bit of worry in
the back of my mind that it's not gonna
go the way that we planned so we'll see
man i i trust that they
everything is showing me that they're
they're thinking about destiny's future
and they're serious in a way that i
didn't see before beyond light that
scared the crap out of me because every
time i showed anything for beyond light
i was just like oh dude i don't know
these supers don't look like they're
thought through
the amount of content that they've shown
like it looks like they've shown all of
it it's gonna be one of those bosses
aramis that we forget about two weeks
after she's gone and you know after the
campaign's launch it just it had all
these red flags and maybe it's just
because i know less about witch queen
that i don't have the same red flags but
it just so far i'm i'm i'm definitely uh
comforted uh by by what i've seen so far
and just the way that they're talking
about it so ignorance fearless it feels
like they sort of got their group back
you know yeah i mean
i'm hype i'm hype and i don't get
honest i don't get super super hyped all
the time with them but this what i am i
mean
one i think
narratively they're the best i've ever
seen them yes and
right now
that is probably my number one
excitement how this transitions what's
gonna happen
and dare i say maybe we get
you know
cade type moment for a transition into
what this new season i mean not the new
season but then the expansion is going
to be right i agree i agree with you
travis that the season i ain't getting
too crazy about yeah
yeah 15 it's like okay what is what are
you going to do to just cross play i
think it's the
narratively i'm i'm curious you know
what happens right but we all know what
the the big thing and and to me
i think that's what this is right this
is to reveal
what you're really looking for and i i
and in this whole sabbath soccer so
narratively
i think we're gonna get something big
they're screaming from the rooftops i
feel so when you start yelling out
bungie you're tweeting and you know
they're doing it the employees are
yelling yeah once the employees yet like
that that is big
also i do think we get
some news with them as a studio
you know maybe some br even if it's
small you know i'm saying some news
what's going on there's a lot going on
with them i find it very interesting
that it's the same day as the xbox
gamescom
day
you know i'll just expect a witch queen
to be part of game pass i talked about
that yeah right that's what i was going
to say loud that's all so at the end of
the day you know to me that would know
just like beyond light that that
expansion is most likely going to be in
game pass and that relationship has been
there we know phil his favorite game is
destiny yeah you know i think they're in
a great relationship both for them i
don't think there's any acquisition type
talk but i think it will be you know
it's like
you know friends of benefits that you
don't need to get married everything's
good the way it is
[Laughter]
they like their independence microsoft
you know we'll rule them with this guy
you can date other people on the side
you know we're good
yeah so it's got that but yeah i'm i'm
looking for narrative but i do think
they're gonna i think they're gonna
deliver i really do i really feel good
about it
um everything's lining up right they're
doing the right things a sandbox
foundation
everything's setting up for something
truly epic
you know for the for which queen but
i'll give it to you e like
you you you you like in the middle
you're like you know
you don't know
my biggest thing is
from what it's set from everything i'm
gathering so far
whether it's as you said the bungee
employees six months ago tweeting out
whole like what they did
yeah bungie like and you're going what
is this you got somebody like pattycakes
who got to go to a community summit
which i know you can't talk about that's
totally fine but i was like they've been
doing those things again where they get
to
get the community involved multiple
times to my understanding like they've
been growing you know they've been
bringing in some of the people you know
like hoplite got to go work there you've
got people who are
just so deep in the community that are
going to be in the mix on this thing
some things are major and can't change
like you know in six months but also
some of the refinement hopefully in that
time that they're trying to do
for which queen can be big enough and
i want to be ecstatic
and i want to be blown away
i just also know as you said travis like
beyond light is this going to be aramis
is this going to be the worm god that we
kill in the story mission on a strike
like there's both sides of that we've
seen of this like
coming to the couch brother what what do
you need what do you need to forget
about the hurt forget about the pain
what do you need
for you to say yo
they did it
that's what i need to hear from you
uh i mean i think either travis has said
it before or somebody like the narrative
to keep going
the narrative is huge as you've said the
narratives is probably in some of the
best places it's going but we can't just
kill sabathune
like we can't do that in the raid it's
like what are you gonna do for the next
year
like an ongoing arc like some of the
ones that i've noticed like for shows
like you have like the little like
procedurals and stuff like that that we
get but the long-going villain in the
background who's like the deeper thing
that you're worried about the fact that
we actually kind of know
who sabathune is and we've been building
up and she's playing all the setting up
all the dominoes and playing puppet
master with quaria and possibly osiris
and however all that stuff is set we
don't know so much so it's like i hope
it isn't just like
here's everything i hope it's like this
this is this year adventure we go on
that starts with witch queen and maybe
you know they kind of take it in that
way but you also know me i do want armor
to matter more
like grinded for the same thing because
it needs to at this point with transmog
especially
once you get a good like three good stat
rolls you can just infuse forever you
don't need armor i need armor to matter
to me because weapons
what we're seeing here the changes the
archetypes the perks they're putting in
they're keeping weapons interesting
enough i'm kind of okay with what those
are doing as long as the exotics kind of
keep being interesting but armor i need
to care about again
and then of course
i don't want actually like which queen i
don't expect a which queen i want a
dungeon that's the other piece okay okay
okay there we go there we go requests i
like it i want i want to carry about
and i want a dungeon
for the story thing i think like
obviously i've said on the show like a
million times and i said it on fire team
chat like every week like it it we need
a long-term villain and we always
thought that the darkness was gonna end
up being that and it just it doesn't
seem like that's gonna happen at this
point it's gonna be like your thing but
i always thought like you know guys like
gaul like they died at the end of the
campaign so you kind of forget that they
were ever a thing if at the very least
if they're not going to be a long-term
villain who survives and then maybe
comes back later
you should kill them at the end of the
year you know what i mean like they
should be the villain for four seasons
where like you're doing that game of
chess back and forth and then their arc
ends when you finally defeat them at the
end i think same thing with sabathune
like introduce her in season 15 but in
the distance have her come hard during
the witch queen expansion and then make
that whole year of content around us
fighting her and then have like an epic
conclusion at the end where you know
it's over and you kind of get the ending
of that campaign i think the reason
they've been limited in their ability to
do that in the past is one because they
they never really fully embraced the
games as a service model and they
expected like oh we're selling you a
campaign it has to have a beginning
middle and then because that's what
people are gonna expect and they were
just a different company back then where
you know activision was still during
forsaken they they kind of had they had
to present like a finished product i
think now they have a lot more freedom
so if they want to mess with that model
and make it like a year-long fight where
they kind of drip the campaign and you
don't actually even finish the full
campaign during during the initial um
season i think they have they have the
ability to do that now so i'll be
interested in seeing it but i i agree
with you you like it the very at the
very least like it can't just we
sabotaging cannot be a footnote she
could not be another era
good point
actually aramis was technically better
because she's not dead technically
i would have taken that with gaul or
with oryx like the fact that we keep
killing everybody so easily yeah not
even easily it's just quickly that i
guess i don't like there's no
development you barely get to know them
as a character well here you go travis
imagine if you killed darth vader in the
first 10 minutes of the movie like
right
yeah you're like why didn't we kill him
and you figure out later on why it
matters but yeah uh no i agree rat did
bring up one other thing i do want to
mention
because we talked about before when it
came to
how many seasons were listed in certain
atop we had a season 16 which is witch
queen we had a 17 and 18 but we don't
have a 19.
i'm honestly wondering if they change up
their seasonal model
cadence pacing and if they're gonna talk
about that on tuesday
because that i think to me is something
you don't think so you don't think they
change it you don't think they talk
about it
i don't think they talk about i don't
think tuesday's about them talking to
their super super core player their
extreme player who is
that's a twab thing like if they're
going to change their seasons i think
tuesday's about big headlines announces
you know catchy release trailers i don't
think they go and talk about like
shotgun spreads yeah i don't know i
think it's a big tuesday event i think
tuesday's about get it's the same thing
as the beyond light hype right they're
just trying to build a pipe try to get
people who have been on the fringes
maybe they've been watching videos but
they're not playing actively right now
or they've heard about destiny but
they're not really that into the game or
you haven't tried it i think it's about
getting those people excited for which
queen
i'm just ready i think there absolutely
should do fewer seasons though
absolutely uh but but i just just
because it like it's so clear that
they're kind of like delaying the game
like here's a public event that is just
like another one you've done like it's
so clear what they're doing but yeah um
i don't know if they'll do it just
because it's such a source of revenue
for them everybody's buying the season
passes and then they have all the uh
stuff you can buy in the everest store
and it keeps the players alive so i
don't even know if that's a
possibility for them i do think it would
benefit all the players if if they got
more time to work on their stuff and we
got some time to play other games
because god man do i
do i you know i've enjoyed this past
like month or so where it's been really
dead because like man i've been able to
just die
yeah
the reason why i struggle is because
remember e we we were at um gcx and we
were literally in the what is it the
seminar slash forum
where they talked about the the need for
the um when these was there the need for
the seasonal model and and how they were
shifting right so
you know from a dev standpoint i mean
i'm not saying it's out of the question
but i just think structurally it kind of
benefits where they're at right now from
a resource standpoint and then kind of
pull everything for the big expansions
the big changes
it's not to get rid of the seasonal
model okay but it's to
as travis said less seasons
but maybe just like a bigger season in
there give it more spacing give them
time to put stuff in because
when you get a season of the worthy or
you get a season of revivals that is
based around a public event
that's not that much now the
storytelling has been cool and we got
like override and we got expunge
override was another public event
basically um with a boss at the end so i
mean you have those types of things
being this focus that you run a hundred
times during the season right if they
get a little longer and those things are
cooler but you only have a couple of
them how's that gonna sit better
than three three extra seasons with
slightly smaller stuff or two extra
seasons with a bigger thing each time
it's just like how many seasons they do
is i think more the cadence that i would
be curious of because
i think they would be better off
spreading it in trimesters instead of
quarters to get more time on everything
and as travis said it's like
they need to accept the fact that people
need a break from destiny
and i think like giving that big like
the time like this for a month people
now are getting ultra hyped because you
know if you're playing pvp you will and
hopefully that feels a little bit better
but yeah the the drip feed as new rad
said is the other piece um the drip feed
on the weekly story like it can't be a
16 week story i'm gonna lose my mind if
that happens so it's like it's a balance
like the shorter seasons you can do like
the ten week story get like six weeks
off and then you get another one but
then those stories also feel like they
need to connect
because you have title where'd she go
then you've got this one and then we're
gonna like bail on yeah so it's just
like the weird anti-connected stories
versus i'm not i'm not suggesting they
drip feed their entire campaign for
their major expansion i'm just saying
imagine if there were only two seasons
you know two seasons in addition to the
the main expansion and they did
self-contained campaigns for each of
those that were all connected and it's
sort of like a beginning a middle of an
end of one larger campaign obviously the
first one would probably be the largest
then you got the second one that maybe
has like a dungeon and then maybe the
third one ends in like a raid that is
like part of the story or something like
that like if they did a model like that
where they connected all three and you
could play all of them right when they
came down but they were like chunkier
had more in it and and were part of the
same story i i just i'm with you you
like they need to be connected and i
think that if there was less content but
it was
bulkier and and they gave it to us and
like these these these big like i just
want a meal man i don't want like
here's one french fry
at the beginning and then like and then
like destiny appetizers or soup just
served to me for like a full year like
it just it just doesn't feel good
which kind of
resembles the expansion model a bit it's
right it's just that's the test
expansion which i like too i was like
but that's the yeah that's the tough
balance it's like how can they get
dark
how can they get closer to
like a a baby expansion basically just
like a a slightly beefier season that
has you know more time to develop
because you say the six month cadence
well if they get eight months to work on
season 18 by the time we get to that you
know that's a long chunk of time but if
they're working on mult there's a if
they're working on another one in
between that that just takes away in
multiple places around it so yeah i
don't know if they would drop that yet
but it was like i would i don't if
that's one of those like you know heart
to hearts like hey we're going to two
seasons instead i'm just that's more the
curiosity than anything but
uh we rambled a lot patty yeah i know
yeah
you got anything else but i also want to
make sure you can uh get to your day you
got anything else you want to add before
we go not too much i'm just excited to
see the employees at bungie really
excited i think that's a good sign right
it's like yeah we don't know what's
coming but but if they're excited and
you can see it i think in the the 12s
it's like escalating there's more more
meat to them um coming out like the
random tweets like people you see me
like there's
there there's stuff that
um you know they're excited and like you
said i can't really talk about the um
the summit i went to other than just
saying it was clear that they're
passionate about the game they're really
excited about what they're building and
you know it's just cool to even just see
more transparency on like the
nitty-gritty pvp stuff like we were
talking about just
like that's communication we didn't have
two years ago and yeah we'll see you
know more and more of that
agreed and i one didn't guarantee you
know the trailer gonna be fire
regardless
that's gonna be one of those when i'm
over here like recording a reaction like
holy dude like there's gonna be yeah
we'll get some reveal
two things about destiny that you could
always count on amazing gum plays i
thought you were gonna say
disappointments but
no
an outstanding
marketing trailers it's gonna be crazy i
was gonna say disappointments in the
trailers that follow
negative nancy
no the trailers are hyped there's like
brand x music they do like the
they did the trailer for season of the
worthy the song that they did is in that
and they just and i just found like
songs from them so it's always been
now their their trailers are like almost
next to nobody else they're they're
crazy
like cod's trailer came out today i'm
like just wait till tuesday you guys got
nothing
like
so
well man um patty thank you so much for
coming on it was a perfect show to have
you on
uh it has been an absolute pleasure sir
thank you for joining us
thank you for having me it's really fun
chat with you guys it's a lot to talk
about today yeah it was a big one i'm
sorry i got a little long but um
it was fun at this point what i want to
do is kind of basically clear the air
and the floor is yours to let anybody
who listens finds this or ever otherwise
to say where they can find you because i
know this is what you do full-time
content and all that fun stuff that you
do amongst all those guitars behind you
in the background and your instruments
and everything
not that much time to play those with
all the youtube videos it's like i'm
busy making destiny videos guitars you
wait um but yeah floor is yours where
the can they find you what are you doing
what are you looking forward to
yeah so um my main uh gig i guess you'd
say is uh on youtube i try to make
videos roughly once a week the channel
is youtube.com pattycakesgaming uh it's
mostly pvp focused but i've actually
been kind of slowly working to do more
pve stuff as well and i think in the
next year so i'll probably kind of
expand my horizons there but if you're
looking for pvp improvement tips to try
to get better you know builds on um you
know what's fun to use and
uh you know what weapons are good i do a
lot of reviews and stuff like that so
it's a fun place to check out i also
stream on twitch so i do that uh
twitch.tv such patty cakes and usually
it's more pvp content as well but i do a
little bit of variety and just kind of
chatting there with people and then all
of my socials are all pattycakesgg so
you can twitter instagram ticktack all
that stuff
nice nice
man
always good
always good love gin sight man really
cool thank you
yeah
nice to have pvp people on yeah
yes you know
travis to keep his segment
going
his long running segment
segment we're up to three now we're up
to three
manifested it
yeah you did
hey if this man gets on a podcast he
makes a segment
that's what he does at least one at
least one well travis what are you up to
man you got anything coming up yours is
usually i'm working on stuff but i can't
tell you what it is cool
i can tell you now uh i i just did a
review for a game called recompile that
is on ign.com uh that went live last
night and uh my next one which i think
i'm getting a code for tonight or
tomorrow morning is uh
for the man eater dlc which i'll be
reviewing for ign as well uh the the
manager expansion so
excited for that and uh other than that
you can watch me here i'm on bitcast
sunday mornings at 8 am and uh
yeah you can follow me on twitter at ty
guy travis if you want to watch me tweet
about destiny star wars and fast and
furious it's basically a salute
yeah if you have thoughts of either of
those two franchises this is your guy
yes yes yes
what do you got besides your four
podcasts a week and
big time in it at last stand media last
iron lords podcast is blowing up if
anybody listens to this please go
subscribe to iron lord podcast youtube
channel please they're not that far away
from 10k just like push them away over
that edge they definitely freezing but
anyway what do you got going on yeah
that's the same the same bit um like i
said defining duke's been cool been
really loving that so you can catch me
there um if you're on patreon the
episode's up now with me and manny
talking about what's been going on very
spicy episode a lot of a lot of stuff
going on i didn't even know about this
game uh boyfriend dungeon that
this drama in this game that i was mad
he put me on i'm like
whoa okay so yeah i learned some things
really mad at like the villain guy or
something yeah like attacking that the
voice actors it's like literally the
equivalent of like they running down on
osiris and they're like yo how dare you
betray the bad guy
no i heard it described once and it's
like you know voice actor does such a
good job that you hate them that means
they did a very good job fantastic job
i always picture and harry potter is
like the example uh
umbridge i cannot stand that character
but i'm like damn it you played it so
well i hate that crazy
exactly i was like that's just talent to
do that but i was like i hate that
character it means you did a good job
but it's like you guys did it wrong and
also somebody tweeted it was like if
you're mad at a voice actor in a video
game you might want to check yourself
because you messed up yeah yeah it's
it's bad so yeah we
you need to check the episode out just
for that alone the boyfriend dungeon
segment is hilarious so jack that i got
very spicy but yeah check that out we've
been doing ultimate kind of game focus
again if you're on the patreon you get
that if you don't want to do that that's
fine we have free 99
on sundays it gets released well last 10
minutes to check that out obviously i
almost podcast sunday 1pm eastern check
us out we've got tony polanco
from pc mag we're going to be talking
games what's going on and game pass and
all that good stuff it's my whole
company yeah oh okay
pc mag is owned by uh the same company
as ign so i know a lot of people
yeah very good but he's been doing it
for a while he's got bylines a lot of
places so yeah check that out and then
of course the the last word on this new
thursday day that i like with the 12
live and raw reactions and awesome
guests you know what i mean like my man
patty cake so it's my man right here so
salute and of course he's good to have
you back man and what is going on with
you sir uh yeah i'm gonna try and finish
this door before tuesday that's my main
goal
um if you
guys if you like metroidvanias or souls
or 2d action at all please play grime
that game is excellent um it's not
perfect
of course like anything but honestly
like for me my playthrough i'd give it a
nine like it was
a good challenge there were a lot of
little quality of life things that they
got right for like seven dudes making a
game
it was a good 18 hours i think um so a
solid size
just like really unique little mechanics
and tweaks and touches to it i mean
there's a couple things i would
definitely change but overall and again
if you need to look up a map that's
probably one thing that helped me but
overall
it's a really unique twist on like a 2d
metroid souls game and that was
like dcp sidequest they actually did an
interview with the developer like oh wow
it's it's just one that's definitely
worth checking out miss 5000 watts
turned me onto it it's just it's
fantastic um playing through death store
right now as well and then of course i'm
gonna be live tuesday morning probably
just eating breakfast having my advanced
gg and just waiting
for the pre-show the show and then
season 15 not sleeping much going to
work at five o'clock on wednesday
morning
teaching the classes that i'm gonna
teach come home and do it again so like
tuesday is gonna be a long one but
exciting um
one thing before i wanted to go patty
cakes favorite type of pancakes
oh boy um i'm pretty traditional i would
say chocolate chip if i had to pick one
but i have had some pretty crazy ones
before i've had like oreo and different
you know all kinds of wild combinations
of things but
i like i did not know exist this is a
world yeah there's actually there's a
fancy breakfast place out in l.a i've
been to when i was visiting that has
like all kinds of different cereal
pancakes and oreos and those wild things
but i'm pretty traditional i go with
like a blueberry chocolate chip banana
that kind of stuff nice nice
i know pancakes are literally your logo
and i meant to ask that earlier and i
smooth forgot so
there's a place around here called um
snooze it's just like an am eatery
they're bacon they live in there oh
they're bacon's so good i lived yeah i
lived in denver for like five years so i
used to go to snooze all the time nice
i'm in dallas so they're apparently
around here too but oh nice um they had
like pancake flights so if you just like
i want to try three different flavors
you get like one of each on this long
plate so i was like no those were
there's been some like s'mores ones and
reese's like peanut butter and chocolate
there's some crazy pancakes yeah
pancakes are excellent i was just i had
to ask the expert over here since it's
literally your entire brand yeah
but that pretty much wraps up this
episode so for all of you guys in chat
on youtube thank you guys if you listen
to this later on audio and you make it
to the end thank you guys find us on
youtube follow all of these amazing
gentlemen
go support them wherever you can and as
we wrap this thing up i just again want
to thank you patty for joining us um
very cool to have you on here
and just couldn't have had a better
timing when it was like hey we got you
booked and cool it's like oh it's the
sandbox squad perfect
so thank you for having me is awesome
yeah
well you can go enjoy your evening the
rest of you guys thank you very much and
for episode number 163 august 19th the
one before the showcase thank you guys
very much and for this episode it's been